I started, you know when I started eating for breakfast? Just almonds. That's it. Just almonds? Just almonds. That's it. Literally. Yep. Are you really eating just almonds for breakfast? Yeah, just almonds and then maybe a yogurt thing. Okay, well so now it's also a yogurt thing. Might want to take the just off the top of that. Welcome to Smartless. Smart Less Smart Less
你知道我早餐吃什么吗？就只有杏仁。就这样？就只有杏仁？就只有杏仁。真的。没错。你早餐真的只吃杏仁吗？对，就只有杏仁，然后可能加点酸奶。好吧，那现在也加了酸奶了。你可能得把“只有”二字收回了。欢迎收听《SmartLess》。
Smart Less Smart Less Smart Less Smart Less
SmartLess
Smart Hey, Cool Dad, Cool Dad, you got the long sleeve shirt on underneath the short sleeve shirt today, huh? Very 90s. It's a very, it's a cold day for, um... So then why don't you just wear a long sleeve golf shirt? No, I don't have a long sleeve golf shirt. So I have this and I have, and if I want to I can take it out.
嘿，酷老爸，酷老爸，你今天在短袖衬衫里面穿了件长袖衬衫，对吧？很有90年代的风格。这天可真冷，为了……那你为什么不直接穿一件长袖高尔夫球衫呢？不，我没有长袖高尔夫球衫。所以我有这件，还有，如果我想的话，我可以把它脱掉。
Why don't you wear your short sleeve golf shirt and just put a sweater over the top of it instead of doing the cool dad thing. I am, I've got a sweater and I'm gonna have a shell because it's kinda rainy and it's very unusually cold for Los Angeles. That's really nice. And I'm teeing off at 12.30. Wait, Tracy bought you both golf shirts.
你为什么不穿你的短袖高尔夫球衫，然后在外面套一件毛衣，而不是搞这种酷老爸的造型。我有穿啊，我有一件毛衣，我还要穿一件冲锋衣，因为有点下雨，而且洛杉矶现在冷得有点反常。那真的很好。我12点30分开球。等等，崔西给你们俩都买高尔夫球衫了。
She did? Yeah, they're here at the house. Oh great. Love her. Did she buy you anything? She did, yes. Driving gloves for the golf cart? Yeah. Yeah.
是吗？对，它们就在家里。太棒了。爱死她了。她给你买什么了吗？她买啦，是的。高尔夫球车的驾驶手套？对。对。
Yeah. She joined me and she got me a new set of clubs. So I'll see you guys later. You don't want to know who I'm playing with today. I'm surprised you didn't ask me. Paul. You're playing with Paul. Paul.
对。她陪着我，还给我买了一套新球杆。所以待会儿见。你们不想知道我今天跟谁一起打球吗？我很惊讶你居然没问我。保罗。你在和保罗一起打球。保罗。
You're playing with Paul. I'm playing Paul, but guess who else? Who you got? You got Paul, our buddy from Toronto. Paul M. we'll call him. Paul Michaelis. And. we'll call him. Paul Michaelis. And then we'll have...
你在和保罗一起打球。我在和保罗打球，但你们猜还有谁？你还有谁？你有保罗，我们来自多伦多的好兄弟。我们就叫他保罗·M 吧。保罗·迈克利斯。还有。我们就叫他。保罗·迈克利斯。然后我们还有……
I got a real friend of the show. Danny Dees. Danny Dees. Danny Dees. I love him. The nicest man and the greatest guy ever in finance. Yes, sure. In many categories.
我请了一位真正的节目之友。丹尼·迪斯。丹尼·迪斯。丹尼·迪斯。我太爱他了。金融界最善良、最棒的家伙。对，没错。在很多方面。
And then our JB, our buddy. You're going to play five, huh? Football legend. Gareth Bale. Gareth's in town. in many categories. And then, our JB, our buddy, football legend, Gareth Bale, Gareth Sinton. You're gonna play five today? Yeah. No, it's me and Paul, Dan and Gareth. Oh, sorry, I'm not great with math. Evidently.
然后还有 JB，我们的好兄弟。你要打五人局，对吧？足球传奇人物。加雷斯·贝尔。加雷斯进城了。在很多方面。然后还有 JB，我们的好兄弟，足球传奇人物，加雷斯·贝尔，加雷斯进城了。你今天要打五个洞吗？对。不对，是我、保罗、丹和加雷斯。哦，抱歉，我数学不太好。显然是的。
So I'm very excited, I'm doing a home game today, recording from Los Angeles for the first time in a while. It feels nice, I've got a microphone on a stand now, instead of a, I'm not comfortable with the New York setup. What if you came home, you've been away for a couple weeks, and then you just looked around, you just started to notice some of my stuff was there. Yeah, your underwear's in the sauna.
所以我非常兴奋，我今天在搞主场作战，好一阵子以来第一次在洛杉矶录音。感觉真好，我现在支架上有一个麦克风了，而不是……我不习惯纽约的那套设置。如果你回到家，你已经离开两周了，然后环顾四周，突然发现我的一些东西在那里。对，你的内衣在桑拿房里。
That would be awful. That's disgusting. And you just notice like Amanda's wearing like an oversized shirt to bed, and you're like, is that Will's shirt? Well, you know what, we're about a minute from that. I know. Well guys, before I get into my guest here,
那太可怕了。太恶心了。然后你发现阿曼达穿着一件超大号的衬衫睡觉，然后你会想，那是威尔的衬衫吗？嗯，你知道吗，我们离那一步只有大约一分钟的距离。我知道。好吧，伙计们，在我请出我的嘉宾之前，
can we just, I heard something recently, a description of a podcast that, you know, we'll never be lucky enough to have a description like this, I think. It's a show about people with more balls than a bowling alley. You know, like, no one- That's Knoxville said that.
我能不能，我最近听到一件事，对一个播客的描述，你知道的，我想我们永远都不会那么幸运能有这样的描述。这是一个关于“胆识过人的人”的节目。你知道的，没人——那是诺克斯维尔说的。
He said you have to have that. Knoxville said, right, Knoxville said, it's called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. Pretty sure I can fly, yeah, yeah, yeah. The Johnny Knoxville host that. He said that. Knoxville said that, right. Knoxville said it's called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. Yeah, yeah, yeah. The giant Knoxville host with Elna Baker. From This American Life. From This American Life. It's about, yeah, these people that do things
他说你必须具备那个。诺克斯维尔说的，对，诺克斯维尔说，它叫《我挺确信我能飞》。《我挺确信我能飞》，对，对，对。约翰·诺克斯维尔主持那个节目。他说的。诺克斯维尔说的，对。诺克斯维尔说它叫《我挺确信我能飞》。对，对，对。这个巨大的诺克斯维尔与埃尔娜·贝克共同主持。来自《这个美国生活》。来自《这个美国生活》。它是关于，是的，这些人做的事情
that have far more courage than the three of us put together would ever even dream of having. Well, thanks a lot. Right, and unlike ours, Pretty Sure I Can Fly is educational and inspiring. Exactly. Yeah, you're not going to learn a whole lot here, but we hide it right there in the title. Yeah, it's a great podcast. Yeah, it's worth checking out.
比我们三个人加起来还要有勇气得多，是我们做梦都不敢去想的。好吧，多谢夸奖。对，和我们的节目不同，《我挺确信我能飞》既有教育意义又很励志。没错。是的，你在这里学不到太多东西，但我们在标题里就把这点说得明明白白了。对，这是一个很棒的播客。对，值得一听。
Anyway, Pretty Sure I Can Fly by Smartless Media is out now with Johnny Knoxville and Elna Baker. So punch it into your nearest podcast playing machine and enjoy. Yeah. All right. Huge apologies to our guests. This has been much too long here for the Regis and Kathie Lee chatter. Here comes our guest.
总之，由 Smartless Media 出品的《我挺确信我能飞》现已上线，主持人是约翰·诺克斯维尔和埃尔娜·贝克。所以快在离你最近的播客播放设备上搜索并收听吧。好的。向我们的嘉宾致以万分歉意。这档雷吉斯和凯茜·李式的闲聊已经持续太久了。我们的嘉宾来了。
Sadly, even though I'm in Los Angeles, I still have not written an intro. Mostly though because I just love this guy. I don't need to write an intro for him. I know him. He's a buddy of mine. I think he's a buddy of both of yours as well, but I'm closer with him, okay?
可悲的是，尽管我在洛杉矶，我还是没有写开场白。不过主要是因为我太喜欢这家伙了。我不需要为他写开场白。我认识他。他是我的好兄弟。我想他也是你们俩的好兄弟，但我跟他更铁，好吗？
I'm a big, big fan of his work. He's an enormous movie star, global, and even just bigger, all-time great guy, he's got some interesting things to tell us. I know you're gonna love this hour. Everybody, ladies and gentlemen, it's Hollywood's Jeremy Renner. Jeremy, come on out.
我是他作品的超级大粉丝。他是一位超级巨星，全球闻名，更重要的是，他是有史以来最棒的家伙，他有一些有趣的事情要告诉我们。我知道你们会喜欢这一个小时。各位，女士们先生们，这就是好莱坞的杰瑞米·雷纳。杰瑞米，出来吧。
There he is. Look at him go! Hollywood's Jeremy Renner. What's going on? This guy's a major movie star. You guys better tighten it up. Look at that. What's happening?
他来了。看他走过来！好莱坞的杰瑞米·雷纳。最近怎么样？这家伙可是个大电影明星。你们最好都打起精神来。看那个。怎么回事？
What's up, man? I wish we were all together, actually. I know, right? I haven't seen some faces on the screen, but it's nice to hear you guys. Jeremy, you know where we're all together? Right here. Right here in the heart.
老兄，最近怎么样？其实我希望我们能聚在一起。我懂，对吧？我在屏幕上没看到过一些面孔，但能听到你们的声音真好。杰瑞米，你知道我们在哪里聚在一起吗？就在这里。就在心里。
I didn't see where you were pointing. Yeah, no, my breasts. I had to reboot my computer right before we started. All my questions are gone, but that's okay. Oh, I can start, I can start. No, yeah, you go. No, I go, yeah. Yeah, Jer, first of all.
我没看到你指哪里。对，没有，我的胸口。我们在开始前不得不重新启动我的计算机。我所有的提问都没了，不过没关系。哦，我可以开始，我可以开始。不，对，你来。不，我来，对。对，杰尔，首先。
Welcome. Yeah, welcome, you look great. Look at the guns already. The guns, baby. of all, welcome. You look great, look at the guns already. The guns. I mean, crazy. You're looking great. I follow you on Instagram as well and I love all your positivity.
欢迎。对，欢迎，你看起来气色真好。看看这肌肉线条。这肌肉，宝贝。首先，欢迎。你看起来真棒，看看这肌肉线条。这肌肉。我的意思是，太疯狂了。你看起来真棒。我也在 Instagram 上关注了你，我喜欢你所有的积极能量。
Wait, what, really? Yeah, I love all the positive comments. You're always so warm and thankful and grateful to your fans and everybody with all the support, with all the tragedy that you've had. And you're doing so great. It's so good to see you. Well yeah, you're busy.
等等，什么，真的吗？对，我喜欢所有积极的评论。你对粉丝和每个支持你的人总是那么温暖、感恩，经历了那么多悲剧之后。你现在做得太棒了。很高兴见到你。好吧，是的，你很忙。
Mayor of Kingstown's out now, right? Started June 2nd, I think, yes? They're on the camera. Coming out June 2nd, yeah. Well when this airs, it'll be out. So unbelievable start to the season there, Jeremy. Yeah, way to go. June 2nd, when back on June 2nd, the show came out.
《金斯敦市长》现在上映了吧？大概6月2日开始，对吧？他们在镜头上了。6月2日上映，对吧。嗯，当这期节目播出时，它就已经上映了。所以该剧的开局真是难以置信，杰瑞米。对，干得漂亮。6月2日，当6月2日回归时，这部剧上映了。
Yeah. Season three. The first time I ever saw you, I just moved to Los Angeles, and I don't know if you'd like, we can cut this if you don't wanna talk about it, but I watched this reality show called The It Factor. It Factor, yeah.
对。第三季。我第一次见到你时，我刚搬到洛杉矶，我不知道你是否愿意，如果我们不想谈这个，我们可以剪掉它，但我看过一个叫《The It Factor》的真人秀节目。《The It Factor》，对。
And it was like one of the first reality shows ever, and you were one of the actors, they followed around to auditions and see about your career. And I loved the series and I had another friend in it as well. And I remember you getting Dahmer or something, playing Jeffrey Dahmer and then, or Swat, and you had a pick between the two or one of the two.
那是史上最早的真人秀节目之一，你是其中一个演员，他们跟着你到处去试镜，看看你的职业生涯。我非常喜欢这个系列，我在里面还有一个朋友。我记得你接到了《达默》或者别的什么角色，扮演杰弗里·达默，然后，或者《反恐特警组》，你必须在两者之间做出选择，或者二选一。
And I was like, oh my God, this guy's gonna be so huge. And we're watching it in real time, you going on auditions and really going Yeah, that was a really random random thing I actually end up doing that show because I did Domber already and we shot we shot that movie in two weeks for like $100,000 so you didn't know what was gonna happen with this tiny little movie So I did it to kind of promote that yeah but then in it turned into like this little Cinderella story
当时我想，哦天哪，这家伙要大火了。我们正在实时观看你参加试镜，而且真的……对，那是一次非常随机、非常偶然的事情，我其实最后去拍那个节目是因为我已经演过《达默》了，我们只花了两周时间、大约10万美元就拍完了那部电影，所以你根本不知道这部小成本电影会怎么样。所以我拍它是为了给它做点宣传，对吧，但后来它却变成了一个灰姑娘似的故事，
because that movie came out and then I got like, William Morris, all these things happened. And then, like you said, the audition for SWAT and all these other movies started coming as like this sort of Cinderella story for a breaking actor in Hollywood. Yeah, and that we watched it with, like we were out long for the ride with you.
因为那部电影上映了，然后我签约了威廉·莫里斯经纪公司，所有这些事情都发生了。然后，就像你说的，为《反恐特警组》以及所有这些其他电影试镜的机会开始接踵而至，对于一个在好莱坞苦苦挣扎的演员来说，这就像是一个灰姑娘般的故事。对，我们当时也在看，就像是一路陪着你经历这一切。
It was really cool. I don't know that anybody would do that today. Do you think anybody, that show would work? I don't know, it'd be hard to kind of catch that. Does anybody know when you're gonna break or have any sort of, right? Yeah, but I mean, think about all those things over the years where they've tried to like
真的很酷。我不知道今天还会不会有人这样做。你觉得会有人觉得那个节目能行吗？我不知道，很难捕捉到那种感觉。有人知道你什么时候会火，或者有任何那种征兆吗，对吧？对，但我的意思是，想想多年来所有那些试图
get behind the scene or whatever, but to actually, to actually lock on to somebody, to an actor, and then have it pay off and actually become a big movie. The odds are pretty rare. And then like months later, it was like Jeremy Renner, you were this huge star and have remained since, so it was really exciting.
了解幕后花絮的尝试，但要真正锁定一个人、一个演员，然后让它获得回报并真正成为一部大电影。这种概率是非常罕见的。然后几个月后，就像是杰瑞米·雷纳，你成了超级大巨星，并且一直保持到现在，所以这真的很令人兴奋。
You know, our buddy Sam Jones did a great documentary on Wilco called... Trying to Break Your Heart. Trying to Break Your Heart, yeah. Where the cameras were with Wilco while they were making Yankee Hotel Foxtrot or Foxtrot Hotel, whatever it is. And the label dropping them
你知道，我们的好兄弟萨姆·琼斯为威哥乐队拍了一部很棒的纪录片，叫……《试图击碎你的心》。《试图击碎你的心》，对。当时摄像机一直跟着威哥乐队，记录他们制作专辑《Yankee Hotel Foxtrot》或《Foxtrot Hotel》或随便什么的名字。然后唱片公司抛弃了他们，
because it was too challenging to listen to and then they went to a different label or made their own, I can't remember. But then it ends up winning the Grammy for best album of the year, I think. And I couldn't believe that cameras were there for that whole thing. Sounds like this is similar.
因为这张专辑太难听懂了，然后他们去了另一家唱片公司或者自己制作，我记不清了。但后来它最终赢得了格莱美年度最佳专辑奖，我想是的。我简直不敢相信摄像机记录了整个过程。听起来这很相似。
Yeah, yeah, you catch a little lightning in a bottle. Yeah, but building off of that, Jeremy, I mean, buddy, watching your career just explode right out of the gate and it has not stopped yet. I mean. Well, first of all, Hurt Locker was just phenomenal. Yeah. And everything you've done since,
对，对，你抓住了那么一点点灵感。是的，在此基础上，杰瑞米，我是说，老兄，看着你的职业生涯一飞冲天，而且至今没有停歇。我的意思是。好吧，首先，《拆弹部队》简直太棒了。对。还有你之后所做的一切，
but that was like the thing, I remember just watching that and being like, who's this fucking dude is? Who's this motherfucker, he's taking all of our jobs. He's just crushing. Were you always so discerning from an early age in your career
但那就像是一个转折点，我记得当时看着那个，心想，这个他妈的家伙是谁？这个混蛋是谁，他抢了我们所有的工作。他简直势不可挡。你从职业生涯的早期就一直这么有眼光吗，
to be able to pick what gave you the strength to say no to certain things and not freak out about your paycheck and your rent? Yeah, yeah, I think that, I don't know where exactly that comes from, I know for me, it was being very clear and focused on what I wanted and also what I didn't want. Early on, I had to do a lot of comedy stuff and I'm like, oh my God, it wasn't trying to go down
能够挑选出剧本，是什么给了你说“不”的力量，让你对片酬和房租不感到恐慌？对，对，我想，我不太清楚这具体是从哪里来的，但我知道对我来说，就是非常清楚和专注于我想要什么，以及我同样不想要什么。早期我不得不做很多喜剧类的工作，然后我想，天哪，我可不想走
that road and I ended up, it wasn't trying to go down that road. And I ended up, that's why Domino is a great turning point for me, to kind of go into darker, sort of deeper, sort of character roles. And I just was just kind of clear. And then if I didn't connect to it, there's an easy no, no matter how much money.
那条路，我最终……我可不想走那条路。我最终……这就是为什么《达默》对我来说是一个伟大的转折点，让我得以进入更黑暗、更深沉、更具角色色彩的角色中。我当时心里很清楚。然后如果我对它没有共鸣，拒绝起来就很简单，不管给多少钱。
I've turned down more money than I'll ever make in life. Because I never did something for money. That's great. And you have to be okay with yourself in that. In order to say no to money, and mind you, I mean, I think even during that It Factors show, I was turning down a lot of money and I had no power, I had no running freaking water.
我拒绝过的钱比我这辈子能赚到的还要多。因为我从来不为钱做事。那太棒了。你必须在内心说服自己接受这一点。为了拒绝金钱，请记住，我的意思是，我想甚至在那个《The It Factor》节目期间，我一直在拒绝很多钱，而我当时毫无权力，我甚至连流动的自来水都没有。
I thought you meant Hollywood power. But I'm living on $5 a month to eat. Like it's Yum Yum Donuts, you get like 13 donut holes, 14 donut holes for 99 cents, I'm crushing those for two weeks. And donut hole a day, it's like, it's brutal, dude. But you know that when you know your limits, right? You know you're allowing yourself to go,
我还以为你指的是好莱坞的权势呢。但我当时靠每月5美元的饭钱过活。就像是“美味甜甜圈”，你花99美分能买到13个、14个甜甜圈球，我靠那些东西啃了两周。一天吃一个甜甜圈球，那日子简直太残酷了，老兄。但你知道当你了解自己的极限时，对吧？你知道你允许自己去想，
it's like, all right, well, I don't have to say yes to something just for money. And so it gives me the power and the balls to say, to note things. I love that. And then Clint Barton comes along, you're like, how much? Well, it wasn't that much. I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
就像是，好吧，我没必要仅仅为了钱对某些事说“好”。所以这给了我权力和胆识去对一些事情说“不”。我太喜欢这样了。然后克林特·巴顿出现了，你会想：多少钱？好吧，其实没那么多。开玩笑的，开玩笑的。
So Heart Locker happens, you get the Academy Award nomination, and is there then a waterfall of really great options for you that become somewhat problematic because you can't do them all? How do you go about picking through all the great stuff you're looking at then after that? I feel like the calendar filled up pretty quickly.
所以《拆弹部队》上映了，你获得了奥斯卡最佳男主角提名，然后是不是有一大堆非常棒的选择涌向你，这反而带来了一些问题，因为你根本无法把它们全演完？面对之后摆在你面前的那么多好东西，你是怎么挑选的？我觉得我的日程很快就排满了。
I don't know. What was next, was the town next? There's a town, yeah, was next. And there's Mission Impossible. And there's Mission Impossible. Then Avengers was booked, but it was shot later, and then it was born, and then it was, there's Hansel and Gretel,
我不知道。接下来是什么，《城中大盗》是接下来吗？《城中大盗》，对，是接下来。然后是《碟中谍》。还有《碟中谍》。然后《复仇者联盟》已经签约了，但拍摄在后面，然后是《伯恩的遗产》，然后是……还有《韩塞尔与格蕾特：女巫猎人》，
and then there's Mission Impossible. So it was like, all that happened probably within six months, so they're all, for the most part, franchises, if you will, so I'm kind of booked up. And so they all got scheduled, so your next, basically your three, four years, five years is booked. Yeah, it was like four years was jammed up. I was gone for four years.
然后又是《碟中谍》。所以这一切大概在六个月内发生，所以它们大部分都是特许经营系列电影，如果你这么认为的话，所以我基本上被预订满了。所以它们都排好了期，所以你接下来，基本上你未来三、四年、五年的时间都被预订了。对，就像四年时间被塞得满满当当。我有四年不在家。
Wow. And how did you deal with that, with being away from home, living out of a suitcase, I mean, that's a, and all the fame too. Like, that transition, talk to us about that. Well, it's actually interesting, because I was kind of very excited to have the opportunities and by the time, born was the last thing
哇。你是怎么应对这一切的，离家在外，靠行李箱生活，我的意思是，这是一场……还有所有的名气也是。像那样的转变，跟我们谈谈吧。嗯，这其实很有趣，因为我当时对拥有这些机会感到非常兴奋，而当《伯恩的遗产》
that kind of came my way, and I'd already signed on to Avengers. That's now, you know, how many a decade of your life, you have to sign on for it. Doesn't mean you're gonna do it, but you sign on for it, right? I'm gonna be 50 years old and fucking tights. Right.
成为最后一部找上门来的作品时，我已经签约了《复仇者联盟》。现在你知道的，你得为之搭上十年的生活。这并不意味着你一定会去演，但你签约了，对吧？我到时候都要50岁了还得穿着紧身衣。没错。
So that's what I was having my conversation with with the team, right? So I'm like, am I doing this? Am I really doing this? And then same with Mission Impossible. You know, I talk with Tom, he's like, all right, well, we're gonna do three of these. I'm like, okay, well, there's,
所以这就是我当时和团队进行沟通的内容，对吧？所以我在想：我真的要演这个吗？我真的要这么做吗？然后《碟中谍》也是如此。你知道的，我和汤姆交流过，他说：“好吧，我们要拍三部这样的电影。”我说：“好吧，那么，
so my whole decade's booked, for the most part, right? And then Bourne comes around, and he's like, all right, well, we're gonna do three of these. I'm like, okay, well, that's... So my whole decade's booked for the most part, right? And then Born comes around and was like, oh, wow, I really creatively obviously love to do this. I love to be involved with Matt, what he did with it. But I had to really pause and say, let me think about this here. I'm kind of jammed up already. And this is also on the face of the thing too, kind of different than Mission Impossible,
我整个十年都被预订满了，基本上是这样，对吧？”然后《伯恩的遗产》找上门来，他就像是：好吧，我们要拍三部这样的电影。我说：好吧，那……所以我的整个十年基本上都被预订满了，对吧？然后《伯恩的遗产》找上门来，心想，哦，哇，从创意上讲我显然非常喜欢拍这个。我喜欢参与到马特所做的事情中。但我必须真正停下来想一想，让我考虑一下这个。我已经把档期塞满了。而且这也是摆在明面上的事情，和《碟中谍》有点不同，那部电影更多是关于汤姆和这类风格。所以这是一次持续了短短24小时的思考过程，但我不得不对此按下暂停键。所有这一切都非常令人兴奋，但我知道我放弃了十年的生活。没错。杰瑞米，你会不会担心当你做出这些决定时，你有没有陷入过低谷？但我知道我放弃了十年的生活。没错，杰瑞米，你会不会担心当你做出这些决定时，你有没有陷入过低谷？
it's much more Tom and this type of thing. So it was a quick 24 hours sort of thinking session on it, but I had to take pause on it. And all of that's very exciting, but I knew I gave up a decade of my life. Yeah. And Jeremy, were you worried that when you make these decisions, did you ever go down? but I knew I gave up a decade of my life. And yeah, and Jeremy, were you worried that when you make these decisions, did you ever go down there?
因为我想知道我是否会想：是的，今天我想拍，但如果我被套牢了，五年后我会有什么感觉？我们不知道这一点。我们不知道这些事情。你可以考虑它，对吧？你唯一能做的就是考虑它。拒绝这些机会简直是个白痴，它们都是绝佳的机会，如果你愿意的话，它们都是高质量的特许经营系列。代价是什么呢？是的，代价是什么？这会在以后由某些事情决定。你知道的，是的，我知道我会错过很多，但我知道它会有个尽头，对吧，对，所以我就想，让我去，
Because I wonder if I would go like, yeah, today I want to do it, but how am I going to feel five years from now if I'm locked in? We don't know that. We don't know those things. You can consider it, right? That's all you can do is consider it. You're an idiot to say no To these things they're amazing opportunities are all quality Franchises if you will at what cost yeah at what cost it will be something all that we determined later You know yeah, and I and I knew is gonna miss a lot But I knew that there was an end to it right yeah, and that's so I can like let me go
让我去尝试一下吧。是的，别误会我，有时候，大多数时候都是惊人的。大多数时候真的非常棒。但随后也会有……你当时还没当爸爸，对吧？对，我当时还不是爸爸。所以这就是为什么我能过得很开心。我当时是个单身汉，我可以只管出门
Let me let me give it a go. And yeah, don't get me wrong, there were times where, most of the time it was amazing. Most of the time it was really great. But then there was like, you know. You hadn't become a dad yet, right? Yeah, I wasn't a dad yet. So that's why I can have a really good time. I was a single guy, I can just go out
然后专注于工作，看世界，对吧？还能拿钱保持身材，所有这些惊人的事情，对吧，太棒了。但我确实很想念我的家人，我和他们感情非常深厚，家族人很多。所以我有连续四年生日都是和我的助理一起过的，我的是1月7日，他是1月8日，
and just focus on work and see the world, right? And get paid to be in shape and all these amazing things, right, it was fantastic. But I did miss my family, right, that I'm very deeply close with, it's very large. And so I had like four birthdays in a row with my assistant, who's, I'm on January 7th, and he was January 8th,
他比我正好小整整十年。所以我们就在阿布扎比的一辆法拉利车里一起庆祝了生日。我的意思是，你知道，那简直是《威尔和格蕾丝》里的一集什么的。对，我们其实拍过。我不知道，但这是一件很棒的事情，你永远不知道未来会发生什么，这是美妙的祝福，你知道从中汲取的视角，我还是会把这一切重新做一遍。我现在没有精力去做了。但那些大制作、大成本、有很多
and he's exactly a decade younger than me. So we just celebrated our birthdays together like in a Ferrari in Abu Dhabi. I mean you know that's an episode of Will and Grace or something. Yeah we actually shot it. I don't know but it's a it was a great thing but you don't know what's what's what I'll come down the road it's a wonderful blessings and you know the perspective to take from that I do the same thing all over again. I don't have the energy to do it now. But the schedule of those huge, huge films with a lot
特技和特效的电影的拍摄日程，其预算允许拍摄速度慢得多，也就是每天推进的剧本页数较少。对于你来说，这算是一个巨大的转变吗？即使我能想象《拆弹部队》的预算也没有这些大片那么高。那种蜗牛般的步伐是什么感觉？因为有时在那些特技电影中，
of stunts and special effects, the budget on those allows for a much slower movement, a pacing as far as knocking down pages each day. Was that a big transition for you coming from, even I would imagine the Hurt Locker was something that was not as highly budgeted as these things. What is that like, that snails pace? Because sometimes on those stunt films,
比如《碟中谍》，难度系数简直是天文数字，特技的复杂程度等等，观众看到的可能只有10秒钟的镜头，你可能需要花上一周时间来拍摄。你该如何保持？或者三周，对吧，对。就像在《碟中谍》里那样，
like Mission Impossible, the degree of difficulty is just astronomical and the stunt complexity and stuff where you're only shooting like, you know, what the audience sees is maybe 10 seconds, it might take you a week to shoot that. How do you keep? Or three weeks, yeah, yeah. Like in Mission Impossible, like that,
整个哈利法塔的戏。在那期间你如何保持专注力等等？嗯，最初我认为主要的区别只是剧组的餐饮服务（Craft Services）。没错。有点不同。对，不错的房车。在房车那边。不过是的，确实需要更长的时间。
the whole Burj Khalifa. How do you keep your focus and whatnot during that? Well, initially I think the main difference is just craft services. Yeah. It's a bit different. Yeah, nice trailer. It's in the trailer side. But yeah, it does take longer.
但其中很大一部分也在于任何涉及体力活动的前期准备。当涉及到那些动作电影时，有大量的训练，（那就是）在去拍摄之前进行长达数月的身体准备。所以当你在拍摄时，你的训练就像一支运动队或一项运动。你必须这样对待它。你最喜欢用什么方式来保持身材？
But a lot of it is like in the prep too for anything that's physical. When it's those physical movies, there's so much, you know, it's months and months of physical prep before you go do it. So then while you're doing it, you're training like an athletic team or an athletic sport. And you have to treat it such. What was your favorite way in which to get in shape?
你喜欢拳击吗？你喜欢有氧运动吗？你喜欢只是进行交叉训练吗？我确信有很多种方式。你保持身材很长时间了。我认为这 realmente 取决于角色真正需要什么。大多数情况下，例如，比如《伯恩的遗产》，那需要最大的体力消耗。
Were you into the boxing? Were you into cardio? Were you into just cross training? I'm sure it's been a bunch of things. You've been in shape for a long time. I think it depends on what the role really requires. Most of them, for instance, like, for instance, like the Born Legacy, that required the most physical.
所以我们必须进行各种混合武术、柔道以及所有不同项目的训练，老兄。简直是—所以你会有那种训练时的意外吗，结果被对方一拳打在脸上，或者你在……时一拳打在别人脸上。我可能确实砸过一两个家伙。话说回来，当你转去拍像《美国骗局》
And so we had to train like all sorts of mixed martial arts and judo and just all the different things, man. It's home- So you get like, have those like training mishaps where you end up getting clocked in the face by the guy or you clock somebody in the face while you're. I might have smashed a dude or two. Now, when you go over to something like American Hustle
或《降临》这样的电影时，不用在片场等候一堆特技和特效，而且你要做更多种类的表演，嗯，那是另一种表演。是的，你喜欢这种转变吗？是的，我的意思是这只是一种，这更多是决定接下工作的考量。
or Arrival is that it must be nice where you don't have to wait around for a bunch of stunt stuff and effect stuff and you're doing much more sort of, well it's a different kind of acting on those films. Yeah, did you love that transition? Yeah, well I mean it's just sort of, that's kind of more in the decision making to do the job.
那些是比较轻松的活儿，有伟大的导演、伟大的剧本和伟大的角色。你可以带着更多的理性思考、更深的情感内核的角色进去，并且有更多的人可以合作。而其他的那些，比如《复仇者联盟》、《伯恩》和所有的《碟中谍》，那里有更多关于特技
Those are the easy ones with great directors and great writing and great characters. You can go in with a lot more cerebral, much more emotional context characters and a lot more people to work with. And the other ones like from the Avengers and Bourne and all those Mission Possibles, there's, it's much more about the stunts
和动作体能的东西。这很有趣，只是需要用到不同的肌肉。理想情况下，你是在两者之间来回切换，对吧？我想是的，为了让这一切保持有趣，对吧？我正在拍《金斯敦市长》第三季，对吧，我以前从未这样做过，重复扮演同一个角色，你演过《黑钱胜地》，而且你大半辈子都在演这些破事。不过那部剧的节奏要快得多，对吧？
and the physical stuff. Which is fun, it's just a different muscle to use. And ideally you're sort of switching back and forth, right? I think so, I mean to keep it all interesting, right, I'm on the third season of Mirror Kingstown, right, I've never done that before, repeated the same character, you've done an Ozark and you've done shit most of your life. And the pace of that though is much faster, right?
哦，简直疯狂，对吧。有这种推动力会让人觉得很有趣，对吧？对，对，其中有些很有趣的事情，就像是一种受控的混乱，就像在如今的电视剧中，尤其是，你知道的，我们在拍摄如果你拍一部像10小时的电影，而时间只用三分之一，那就太疯狂了。我们马上回来。本集部分内容由 Liquid I.V. 赞助。伙计们，这周末快到90华氏度了（约32摄氏度）。
Oh, it's nuts, right. That's enjoyable that there's momentum, yeah? Yeah, yeah, it's something interesting about it, it's like a controlled chaos in like In television today, especially, you know, we're shooting If you shoot like a film like a 10-hour film and a third of the time, you know, it's crazy We'll be right back This episode is brought to you in part by liquid IV guys, it's almost like 90 degrees this weekend
天气越来越热，夏天来了。每个人都会流汗、口渴和脱水。这就是为什么我们需要 Liquid I.V.。我们的身体有60%到70%是水，所以当我们脱水时，我们会感到失衡。你知道那些迹象：思维模糊、疲劳，那种黏糊糊的感觉。单支 Liquid I.V. 就能提供卓越的水合作用，
It's getting hot, it's summertime. Everybody's gonna be sweating and thirsty and dehydrated. That's why we need Liquid IV. We're made of 60 to 70% water, so when we're dehydrated, we feel imbalanced. You know the signs, fogginess, fatigue, that kind of just like yucky feeling. A single stick of Liquid IV delivers superior hydration
其电解质含量是顶尖运动饮料的三倍，外加八种维生素和营养素。它是为了身体耐力、精神清晰和整体健康而设计的水合方案。难怪它是美国排名第一的粉状水合饮料品牌。我早在2010、11年左右拍摄《三个臭皮匠》时，
with three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients. It's hydration for physical endurance, mental clarity, and overall well-being. It's no mystery why they're the number one powdered hydration brand in America. I was filming Three Stooges back in 2010, 11,
诸如此类的事情，我们在佐治亚州亚特兰大拍摄，连续大约三个月，每天气温都高达110华氏度（约43摄氏度）。如果当时我有 Liquid I.V.，我肯定能轻轻松松地挺过去，毫无问题。那时候他们可没有这种东西。我真希望、希望、希望当时有。每当我去海滩时，
something like that, and we filmed in Atlanta, Georgia, and it was like 110 degrees every single day for like three months. Had I had Liquid IV, I would have skated right through it with no problem. They didn't have anything like that back then. I wish, wish, wish they did. When I go to the beach,
我总是带上一包 Liquid I.V.，而且它总是管用。它总能帮我挺过来。它让我感觉好多了，因为我知道我通过 Liquid I.V. 补充了水分。把你的普通水变成非凡的水合饮料。使用 Liquid I.V.，在 liquidiv.com 网站购买首单即可享 20% 的折扣，
I always bring like a pack of Liquid IV, and it always works. It always gets me through. It makes me feel so much better because I know I'm hydrated with Liquid IV. Turn your ordinary water into extraordinary hydration. With Liquid IV, get 20% off your first order of liquid IV when you go to liquid IV comm and use code smartless at checkout
结账时使用代码 smartless。在 liquidiv.com 购买时使用优惠码 smartless，即可在今天享受更好水合体验的首单 20% 折扣。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。今年过得真快。2024年已经过去一多半了。我超级、超级自豪的一件事就是我和斯科蒂的关系，18年了。你能相信吗？18年。所以我仍然想经营它，让它每一年都变得更好。
That's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today using promo code smartless at liquid IV comm The show is sponsored by better help This year's gone by so quickly already. It's already like a little past midway of 2024. And something I'm super, super proud of is my relationship with Scotty, 18 years. Can you believe it? 18. So I still want to work on it and make it even better every single year.
所以很幸运能找到这样一个人一起度过人生。当生活过得如此之快时，花点时间庆祝你的胜利并为今年剩下的时间做出调整是很重要的。心理治疗可以帮帮你盘点你的进展，并为接下来的六个月设定可实现的目标。如果你最近听过《SmartLess》，你就知道我痴迷于为自己设定目标和人生路标。
And so just lucky that way that I found somebody to go through life with like that. And when life goes so fast, it's important to take a moment to celebrate your wins and make adjustments for the rest of the year. Therapy can help you take stock of your progress and set achievable goals for the next six months. And if you recently listened to Smartless, you know I'm obsessed with setting goals and goalposts for yourself to hit.
如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线进行，旨在提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与持证心理治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。花点时间。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com/SmartLess，首月即可享受 10% 的折扣。网址是 BetterHELP.com/SmartLess。本期《SmartLess》部分内容由 Skinny Pop 爆米花赞助。所以在我们家，每当我们在看电影时，我们都有一些小小的糖果罐，对吧？每个罐子里都有不同品牌的糖果。我们在其中一个罐子里做的事情是倒出一些巧克力，然后我们在里面放了 Skinny Pop 爆米花。
If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Take a moment. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. So in our home, whenever we watch a movie, we have little tiny candy jars, right? And each one we have different brands of candies. And what we did with one of them was empty out some of the chocolate and we put Skinny Pop in there.
真的。所以我抓了一小把这些零食，一小把这些零食，然后从 Skinny Pop 的罐子里抓了一大碗 Skinny Pop。这很奇怪吗？我不觉得。Skinny Pop 原味爆米花非常美味，
For real. So I grabbed a little handful of these treats, a little handful of these treats, and then like a big bowl of skinny pop out of the skinny pop jar. Is that weird? I don't think so. Skinny Pop Original Popcorn is delicious,
而且它只用三种简单的成分制成。我太喜欢了。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop 还提供各种美味的口味，从切达墨西哥胡椒到甜咸焦糖。现在就选购 Skinny Pop 吧。现在回到节目中。你是如何熬过来自像本·阿弗莱克这样的人的
and it's made with just three simple ingredients. I love that. In addition to their original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from cheddar jalapeno to sweet and salty kettle. Shop Skinny Pop now. And now back to the show. How were you able to struggle through the really outrageously poor direction from a
那种极其糟糕的导演指导的？你是怎么拍完《城中大盗》的？他电影最后呈现银幕上的结果简直是个奇迹。是吗？好吧，那就给我们讲讲吧。好吧，他很棒，老兄。他很棒。我记得在那个项目上跟本开过会，我以前从没见过他，我就想，我想我跟他隔着麦克风坐在一起的第一次会议，
guy like Ben Affleck? How did you get through the town? It's just a miracle the results that end up on the screen on his films Was it? Well, just just walk us through it. Yeah. Yeah, he's great, man He's great. I remember meeting with Ben on that I didn't that's first time I met him I'm like how I think my first meeting with it with him sitting across the mic How my first question to him was like, how are you gonna direct this thing,
我对他的第一个问题是：你打算怎么一边导演这部电影，一边演戏，还当主演？我的意思是，你算是个还凑合的演员，我的意思是，你怎么能指望自己又导演又演好这东西呢？我当时有点在跟他开玩笑。他很酷，他呢，就是本。他是个野兽，而且很谦虚。他太优秀了。而且他太聪明了，老兄。
and act, and star in it? I mean, you're kinda okay actor, I mean, how are you expected to direct and act this thing? Kinda fuckin' with him. He's cool, he's, you know, Ben. He's a beast, it's humble. He's just so good. And he's so damn smart, man.
跟他的合作真的非常、非常棒。我真的学到了，我的意思是，他给了我太多的自由。我的意思是，他说，我们不会去练方言口音。我这辈子从来没去过波士顿。对。对此一无所知，对吧？然后他说，我们不会请任何方言教练。
Working with him was so, so great. And I really learned how, I mean, he gave me so much freedoms. I mean, he says, we're not gonna do dialects. I've never been to Boston in my life. Yeah. Don't know anything about it, right? And he's like, we're not gonna do any dialect coaches.
我说，好吧，太棒了。那他妈的我该怎么办？我说，好吧，他把我介绍给了一群刚出狱的人。有一群持械抢劫犯和诸如此类的混蛋、银行劫匪，所以我只是在城里的酒吧里和这些家伙混了几个星期。然后我渐渐找到了这个角色，
I'm like, okay, great. What the fuck am I gonna do then? I'm like, all right, he introduced me to a bunch of people that just got out of prison. Had a bunch of armed robbers and all that shit, bank robbers, so I just hung out with these guys in the bars for a couple weeks in town. And then I kind of found the character
找到了我要怎么演。哦，太酷了。不会吧。太酷了。对，对，所以就是这样，但如果我们不是在波士顿拍摄，我可就彻底搞砸了。对。
and found what I was gonna do. Oh, that's cool. No way. That's cool. Yeah, yeah, so it was, but if we didn't shoot in Boston, I would have been royally screwed. Yeah.
但谢天谢地，谢天谢地我们在那里，因为我需要的一切资源都在那里。然后他只是想，他太聪明了，他只是让我做我自己想做的事，一开始他会在我跟他对戏时跟着我的台词动嘴型。天哪。然后我说，我不得不把头转开，
But thank God, thank God we were there, because all of my access to what I needed was there. And then he just wanted to, he's so smart, and he just kind of let me do my thing, and at first he would start to mouth my lines as I was acting with him. Jeez. And I'm like, I had to turn my head,
心想，我要狠狠揍这个混蛋一顿。我要狠狠揍这个王八蛋一顿。但这只会惹恼我，让我更有动力去对付这家伙。但那是我们拍的第一场戏。而且我想他之后再也没这么干过了。不过是的，他很棒，老兄。他真的很棒。
I'm like, I'm gonna smash this motherfucker. I'm gonna smash this fucker. But only pissed me off, they'd get me more in the mood with this guy. But it was like the very first scene we shot. And I don't think he did it after that anymore. But yeah, he was great, man. He really was so great.
他工作极其拼命，老兄。而且，我真的，我爱上了他，对他充满了敬意。他其实是我认识的最聪明的人之一。他真的、真的很聪明。你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？你看那些电影，特别是那些波士顿电影，
He was working his butt off, man. And, but I really was, I fell in love with him and have so much respect for him. He's just one of the smartest guys I know, actually. He's really, really smart. You know what's funny? You watch those movies, specifically those Boston movies,
如果你问波士顿本地人他们最讨厌什么，而你们在那部电影里干得太出色了。干得太棒了。我以前也和马特谈过这个。你看其他电影，里面的人在说波士顿口音，我不会点名，因为有很多超级大牌、非常著名的演员
and if you ask people from Boston one of the things that they hate, and you guys did such a good job in that movie. Such a good job. And I've talked about this with Matt before, too. You watch other movies where people do Boston accents and I'm not gonna name them because there are a lot of really big names, really famous actors
他们拍过大型波士顿电影，结果口音糟糕透顶。波士顿人恨死这个了。他们气得要命。如果这些人有一点点概念，我说的是那些大牌闪耀的名字。你走过去，他们他妈的——给我们学学其中一个名字听起来是什么样的。
who've done big Boston movies and the accents are fucking terrible. And people from Boston hate it. They get pissed off. And if these people had any idea, and I'm talking big shiny names. You come in and they fucking- Tell us what one of the names sounds like.
它听起来有点押韵……老兄，老兄，听我说，老兄。你别想让我他妈的……经典啊，宝贝，想让我说点关于这些混蛋的坏话……不。你知道吗？我以前在死去的消防局工作。我兄弟在埃迪森公司工作。
It sort of rhymes with... Dude, dude, let me say this, dude. You're not gonna get me fucking classic, baby, trying to get me to say something about these fucking... No. You know what? I used to work for fucking Dead and Fire Department. My brother works for fucking Edison.
给老子闭嘴，老兄。不，去你的。等等，杰瑞米，你是怎么成为今天的杰瑞米·雷纳的？回到我们今天谈论的第一件事，当时我想，天哪，我看着你，看着你崭露头角，你身上有那种无畏的冲劲，只想变得伟大，而不去担心别的什么，
Shut the fuck up, dude. Nah, fuck you. Wait, Jeremy, how did you become Jeremy Renner, the guy we know today? Going back to the first thing we talked about today, when I was like, oh my God, I watched you, and you coming up and you had all this kind of chutzpah to just wanna be great and not worry about anything else
只关注表演的艺术，那股劲儿是从哪来的？你从小就是受了什么启发吗？我得说，肖恩，你可真有种（hudspud），居然用了“hudspud”这个词。对，还带有加强版的“hudspud”。你从哪儿……我的意思是，你知道的。白面包约翰尼在这儿呢。说吧，杰瑞米。
but the art of it, where did that come from? Were you a kid that was inspired by something? I gotta say, Sean, you've got a lot of hudspud to use the word hudspud. Yeah, with the extra hudspud. Where do you get, I mean, you know. Johnny Whitebread over here. Go ahead, Jeremy.
消防局。我……直到上大学我才真正发现演戏这回事。真的吗？哦，真的吗？对，对，在戏剧系。所以我一开始是抱着学犯罪学的想法去的，或者计算机科学之类的破专业，然后选修了一门课。
Fire department. I had a, I didn't really discover acting until I was in college. Really? Oh, really? Yeah, yeah, and in theater. So I went in with a criminology sort of idea I was gonna study or computer science or some shit and then took an elective.
我想我告诉过你，杰森，当我们在唐尼餐厅吃晚饭时我可能跟你提过这件事，我在选课时看到了一门选修课，表演就是其中之一。我想：我上这门演讲课，试试这个表演好了。我脑子里唯一闪过的、我对表演的全部认知就是迈克尔·J·福克斯
And I think I told you, I might have mentioned this to you Jason, when we had dinner at Downey's, but I saw an elective when I was signing up for the courses and acting was one of them. I'm like, I'll do this speech class, I'll try this acting thing. The only thing that popped in my brain, what I knew about acting was Michael J. Fox
和你他妈的，杰斯，对吧？因为他演了那个《天才老爸》还有所有这些该死的电视剧，那是我仅知道的东西。那是我看过的，对吧？成长过程中看过的所有这些。所以我想：他妈的，我去试试那个。然后就一头扎进去了。这家伙能行。
and fucking you, Jace, right? Because he shows these fucking family ties and all these goddamn, just something I knew. It's what I watched, right? Growing up, all those things. So I'm like, fuck, I'll try that thing. And went into it. This guy can do it.
对，这个混蛋能行。我他妈也能干那破事。不，但那只是我看的，我大概能产生共鸣的东西。无论如何，我爱上了戏剧，然后开始学习戏剧和心理学，从此一发不可收拾。哇，真是一段经历。
Yeah, this fucker can do it. I can do that shit. No, but that's just kind of what I watched, what the, I guess, related to. And then anyway, fell in love with theater and then started studying theater and psychology and just ran from there. Wow, which is one of the things.
所以我当时大概18、19岁，然后，就一直坚持做那个。有趣的是，因为你真的很像那种“演员的演员”，你知道我的意思吗？就像你——非常自然。对，非常自然，你身上有种特质，你非常严肃，你能看出你对自己的手艺极其认真，
So I was like 18, 19, and yeah, just stuck with that. Well, it's funny, because you are such a sort of actor's actor, too, you know what I mean? Like you've got like- Very natural. Yeah, very natural, and you've got this thing, you're very serious and you can tell that you take your craft really seriously
而且你知道一切都是深思熟虑的，绝不是凭运气，你不是在寄希望于某个镜头能侥幸拍好。你知道我的意思吗？对，所以有趣的是，这似乎来得有点晚，因为看起来它真的很自然。嗯，我的意思是，那只是来自于——
and that you're very, you know, everything's well thought out, nothing's by mistake, you're not just hoping to get lucky in a take. You know what I mean? Yeah, and so it's funny that it kind of came to you later because it seems like it's really such a, it comes so naturally. Well, I mean, that just comes,
而且你非常……你知道的，一切都深思熟虑，没有什么是偶然的，你不仅仅是在拍摄时碰运气。你知道我的意思吗？是的，所以很有趣的是，这似乎是后来才对你有所启发，因为这看起来真的很自然。嗯，我的意思是，这只是……
I think that's the psychology sort of part of it. And you have to, I think there's a self-awareness and a confidence that, you know, that comes from doing stage. You see a lot of, when people are stage actors, they hold it in their body a bit more. They're not just doing a scene or a thing. They're kind of immersed in their body and spirit.
我觉得这是其中心理学的一部分。我觉得，你知道的，演舞台剧会带来一种自我觉察和自信。你会发现很多时候，当人们是舞台演员时，他们的身体会更有力量感。他们不只是在演一场戏或做一件事，而是把身心都沉浸其中。
Because you have to do it for an hour and a half, two hours on stage, right? You have to really embody it longer than we do when we're doing television and film. Yeah, that's a good point. Was music something that was sort of pulling at you as well? Did you have to sort of make a decision with yourself whether you were gonna kind of put all your weight behind one or the other?
因为你必须在舞台上连演一个半小时、两个小时，对吧？相比我们拍电视和电影，你必须更长时间地去真正融入角色。对，说得好。音乐也是吸引你的事物之一吗？你当时是否需要在内心做一个决定，看是要把全部精力押在其中一个上面？
No, no, I never considered music as a career. It's always a form of therapy, artistic... A hobby? Yeah, well, that's so much a hobby. I don't really believe in hobbies. I feel like either do something or you don't. I don't have fucking time for hobbies. That's hysterical.
不，不，我从未把音乐当成一种职业。它一直是一种疗愈的方式，是艺术的……一种爱好？对，与其说是爱好。其实我不太相信什么爱好。我觉得要么你就去做一件事，要么就别做。我他妈才没时间搞什么爱好。太搞笑了吧。
You know what I mean? Very good. I don't have time to just dip my toe in the water. I'm not taking a fucking bath here in life, right? Just dipping my toe in it. It's not happening. So, you're gonna do something, or yeah, yeah, you do it or you don't, right?
你知道我的意思吗？很好。我没时间只是把脚趾伸进水里试探。我这辈子可不是来洗澡的，对吧？只把脚趾伸进去试探。没这回事。所以，要么你就去做一件事，对，对，要么你就去做，要么就不做，对吧？
So... Yeah, Jason, you dumb fuck. Yeah, you're right. I didn't want to be a player of music, right? I didn't want to be a guitar player or a drummer, which I am those things, or a piano player. I don't have the time or patience, or even excellence or skill set to be able to do that.
所以……对啊，杰森，你个蠢货。对，你说得对。我不想当一个音乐演奏者，对吧？我不想当吉他手或鼓手（虽然我确实会这些），也不想当钢琴手。我没有那个时间和耐心，甚至没有那种卓越的才华或技能去做到这一点。
What I did want to do is be able to play these instruments to compose, to have a form of expression. Music is a wonderful form to express. And it's wonderfully shared as well. You can't really share poetry so much as you can with music. It's more uniting in its experience. And so I love music for that. And that'll always be near and dear to me
我真正想做的是能够弹奏这些乐器来搞创作，拥有一种表达的形式。音乐是一种绝佳的表达方式。而且它也很适合分享。诗歌可没法像音乐那样广泛分享。它的体验更能凝聚人心。所以我很热爱音乐的这一点。它将永远贴近我的内心，
and very important to me in my life. But I don't want some record label saying, you gotta do this, you gotta do that. I'm like, fuck off, or I have to do something. I do it for the purity of it for me and the expression of it for me. Do you have time to still play music with Sons of the Pioneers?
对我的人生非常重要。但我可不希望有什么唱片公司对我说，你得这样，你得那样。我会觉得，滚开，或者我非得去做点什么。我做音乐纯粹是为了它本身的纯粹性，为了我自己的表达。你现在还有时间跟“开拓者之子”乐队一起玩音乐吗？
No, no, I just do stuff in the studio. Yeah, okay. Do stuff in the studio at this point. And like I did for the, from after the accident, I put together an EP of a collection of songs that were about the life, death, and recovery of this last sort of 16 months of my life or a collection of songs that were about the life, death and recovery of this last sort of 16 months of my life or a year of my life.
没有，没有，我只在录音室里搞点创作。好吧，好吧。现在就是在录音室里搞点东西。就像我为……从事故发生后，我制作了一张EP，里面收录了一些歌曲，讲述了我人生过去这十六个月来的生活、死亡与康复，或者说是一组关于我过去十六个月或是一年人生的生活、死亡与康复的歌曲。
And I put out the seven songs on the anniversary of this year. Yeah, that's really heavy. I didn't know that. Yeah, I wanna hear about that. Yeah, me too. And can you talk a little bit about that? I mean, obviously we all heard the devastating news
然后我在这一年的周年纪念日发布了这七首歌。哇，这真的太沉重了。我之前不知道。对，我想听听关于这个的故事。对，我也是。你能稍微聊聊这个吗？我的意思是，显然我们所有人都听到了那个令人心碎的消息，
when the accident happened, and then of course, that you sort of pulled through, and obviously pulled through with colors now, but what a time in your life, and could just walk us through that a little bit, if you could. Yeah, and I'd like to know just personally, to add it to that, is like, what do you,
就是事故发生的时候，然后当然，你挺过来了，而且现在显然是以极佳的状态挺过来了，但这真是你人生中的一段特殊时期，如果可以的话，能跟我们稍微讲讲整个过程吗？对，我还想从个人的角度了解一下，顺便问一句，你觉得，
it's a common question, I'm sure, but what do you see differently now that you're on the other side of it? We could've waited for him to answer the first one. I guess, yeah, I guess the answer to that is like. Yeah, no, don't start at the end like Sean's asking you to. Let's go with the beginning. Let's help Tracy out in Wisconsin
这肯定是个常见问题，但既然你已经走出了阴影，现在看待事物有什么不同吗？我们可以等他回答第一个问题。我想是的，我想对这个问题的回答就像是……对，不，别像肖恩要求的那样从结局开始。我们从头讲起吧。帮帮威斯康星州的特蕾西，
and tell her what you were doing and what happened. And action. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, look, it's probably one of the greatest things that's happened to me in my life. Yeah, wow. And it's not just because it happened to me, it happened to, well, we're talking about it now because you guys are aware of it.
告诉她你当时在做什么，以及发生了什么。3、2、1，开拍。对，对。对，听着，这可能是我这辈子经历过的最棒的事情之一。哇。而且不仅仅是因为它发生在我身上，它发生在了……好吧，我们现在在谈论它，是因为你们知道了。
And so there's a lot of people around this planet. It became a very personal experience that happened on my property. He's trying to save my nephew from getting ran over by this snow plow and snow cap. But it's turned into not such a private experience. I didn't know why. I was already on life support,
所以这个星球上有很多人。这变成了一次非常私人的经历，就发生在我的房产上。他试图救我的侄子，不让他被铲雪车和积雪压过去。但这并没有变成一次那么私人的经历。我当时不知道为什么。我当时已经靠生命维持系统维持生命，
and while everybody else was getting, becoming aware of this incident. And then I wake up from it, and I'm like, why is everybody freaking out? I'm fine, I'm gonna get out of this hospital in two days, I'm walking out of here, speed's no problem. At least that's what the drugs are telling me. I must be as high as a kite thinking that, right?
而与此同时，其他所有人都开始知道了这起事故。然后我醒了过来，心想：为什么所有人都在大惊小怪？我很好啊，我两天内就能出院了，我要走着离开这里，速度根本不是问题。至少药物是这么告诉我的一定是嗨得不行才会这么想，对吧？
But there's a unifying understanding of what was about to become knowledge of who I am as a man a brother a father and a person Not famous for what I did for a living, you know, I'm not Hawkeye anymore. I'm like, oh, this is Jeremy Renner He overcame this incident or is overcoming this incident and there's something really fucking gratifying about that Where that changed my life.
但大家对一个即将成为众所周知的我——作为一个男人、一个兄弟、一个父亲和一个人的我——有了一种凝聚共识的理解。我不再是因为谋生而出名的那个英雄了，你知道的，我不再是鹰眼了。我心想，哦，这就是杰瑞米·雷纳，他战胜了这场事故，或者说正在战胜这场事故，这种感觉他妈的太有成就感了。这改变了我的人生。
Because I never liked being a celebrity. I never liked being adored for, people call me a hot guy, whatever. But being known for who you are as a human is really fucking cool. Something you did completely on your own. I mean, obviously the help of all the medical staff. People treat you differently. They treat me differently now. They don't treat me like a fan of Hawkeye or whatever.
因为我从来不喜欢当名人。我从来不喜欢因为人们叫我性感男人之类的而被崇拜。但因为你作为一个人的真实本质而被人们认识，这他妈太酷了。这是完全靠你自己的力量做到的。当然，少不了所有医护人员的帮助。人们对待你的方式变了。他们现在对我的态度不一样了。他们不再把我当成鹰眼粉丝或者别的什么来看待。
Here's an example. On March, like two months, three months after the accident, I took my daughter to the Magic Mountain in LA, right, in Valencia, to ride all these roller coasters. I got cleared with all my breaks. Go home and ride these things. But it was like, I had to take the little cart around, the little golf cart thing you have to drive around,
举个例子。三月份的时候，也就是事故发生两三个月后，我带着女儿去了洛杉矶的魔术山，就在瓦伦西亚，去玩所有的过山车。我的骨折全都康复了，医生批准了。回家去玩这些项目吧。但我得坐着那个小推车到处走，就是那种你得开着到处转的小高尔夫球车，
because I couldn't walk very far. I could maybe walk like 15, 20 feet. So I had to drive this car around. But everywhere I went, it wasn't like I was being quiet, or got it, you know? I was just being me. I had a boombox, I brought plastic music, I think I'm having a good time.
因为我走不了太远。我大概只能走个15、20英尺。所以我必须开着这个车到处转。但无论我走到哪里，并不是说我在保持低调，或者刻意隐蔽，你知道的？我只是在做我自己。我带着一个手提音响，放着流行音乐，我觉得自己过得很开心。
But I go up the line, right? They let me sort of go in the front of the line. But people were like, it was Rudy, like slow clapping. And like, we're glad you're okay, da, da. It was such like a wonderful camaraderie. Like normally that situation would be like, oh, let me take something from you, I deserve a selfie, I want this, I want this, touch me, whatever.
但我走到队伍前面，对吧？他们让我插队到了最前面。但人们的表现是，就像鲁迪那样，慢动作鼓掌。然后说，我们很高兴你没事，等等。那种感觉就像是一种美妙的情谊。通常情况下，那种情况会变成：哦，让我从你身上索取点什么，我得合个影，我要这个，我要那个，摸摸我，诸如此类的。
Now it's like much more, there's a level of like. Give. Yeah, it was. But you gave... That's a wonderful shift that happened. Yeah, I think that because you've given so many people so much pleasure through your art and through what you do, that that applause is thank you for that,
现在感觉更像是，有一种……给予。对，确实如此。但你付出了……那是一个非常美妙的转变。对，我想是因为你通过你的艺术和你的所作所为给那么多人带来了快乐，所以那些掌声是对这份快乐的感谢，
and we're so glad that the guy that we love is doing great. It's really cool. But also it's that feeling, just that getting that love, right? Feels so good. Yeah, it made me believe in goodness in people that I didn't fucking think existed. Yeah, I love that.
我们真高兴我们爱的那个人现在状态大好。这真的很酷。但同时也是那种感觉，仅仅是获得那种爱，对吧？感觉太棒了。对，它让我开始相信人性中的善良，而我以前他妈的以为这种善良根本不存在。对，我喜欢这样。
In a big, big way, right? Not just a group of people, and not just a couple people in my hometown or my neighborhood. This is like in a pretty global way that this is happening. I think people are, for the most part, people are good. I do. Yeah, I know, I believe that too.
而且是以一种非常非常大的方式，对吧？不仅仅是一群人，也不仅仅是我家乡或街坊邻居里的几个人。这种事情是以一种相当全球化的方式在发生。我觉得人们在大多数情况下都是善良的。我真的这么认为。对，我懂，我也这么认为。
I just don't think they're in the right situations to have that come out. You're right, but you had spent so much time being somewhat, I don't know if I'm using this word correctly, but somewhat objectified, you know, which is kind of baked into the cake. It's kind of, it's what we do. We all have public jobs,
我只是觉得他们没有处在合适的处境中来把这种善良激发出来。你是对的，但你花了大量时间处于一种……我不知道我这个词用得对不对，但某种程度上被客体化了，你知道的，这有点像是命中注定的。这有点像，这就是我们的工作。我们都有公众工作，
and there's certainly nothing to be resentful about with that, but at your level, I'm sure you just saturated with you being sort of approached and acknowledged as an object and that there's a bit of an ownership from the audience because of that. And basically, I can understand that, but this was a different kind of acknowledgement.
对此当然没什么好怨恨的，但在你这个级别，我确信你已经厌倦了那种被当成客体来接近和认同的经历，因此观众对你产生了一种所有权的感觉。基本上，我能理解这一点，但这是一种不同的认同。
It was, we're actually people, we're not looking at Jeremy as a commodity, we're looking at him as a human being, and we could have died just like he almost died. All right. Well, also they became allies. We were equals and they were my ally. They were like, it's everyone,
这是，我们其实都是人，我们不是把杰瑞米当成一件商品来看待，我们是把他当作一个活生生的人来看待，我们可能也会像他一样差点死去。好吧。而且他们也成了盟友。我们是平等的，他们是我的盟友。他们就像是，每一个人，
every thought or prayer, if you will, is something I actually needed. I needed everything to recover. Right, and on Instagram, when I saw you post that video of you running, it was like one day you were, the accident happened, and it seemed like a week later, but I'm sure it was six months or a year later, you're jogging uphill this steep driveway.
每一个念头或祈祷（如果你这么叫的话），都是我真正需要的东西。我需要一切来康复。对，在Instagram上，当我看到你发那个跑步的视频时，感觉就像前一天事故才发生，好像过了一个星期——但我确信那是六个月或一年后——你正在这个陡峭的车道上往上慢跑。
I was like, oh my God, I can't even do that and I didn't get hit by a snowmobile. Like, you know what I mean? Well, but hang on, Sean, what if we put like a stir fry thing right at the top of it? That's a good incentive. You'd get up that hill. Good incentive, I could make it.
我当时想：天哪，我甚至都做不到这一点，而且我还没被雪车撞过。就像，你知道我的意思吗？好吧，但是等等，肖恩，如果我们在坡顶放一份炒面会怎么样？那是个很好的动力。你就会爬上那个坡了。好动力，那我肯定能做到。
Jeremy, you told me something at that dinner and I hope you're comfortable relaying it on this. It was a story about, you know, to sort of make it sort of the stupid description of it, basically seeing the light and how there is an absolute similarity, if not identical type of experience that is repeated around the world from people that get this close to death.
杰瑞米，你在那次晚宴上跟我说过一件事，我希望你能在节目里讲出来，你很乐意这么做。那是一个关于，你知道的，如果用一个有点愚蠢的描述来概括的话，基本上就是看到了光，以及那些濒死边缘的人在世界各地所经历的事，有着绝对的相似性，甚至可以说是完全相同的体验。
And the way you relate it to me was in a way that was so sort of encouraging about possibly what that moment is to the point where, and I don't want to put words in your mouth, but it sounded like you no longer have as much a fear of death as you did before. And after hearing that story, I too share, I'm not looking forward to that moment, but I'm not as fearful of it as I once was.
你跟我讲述这件事的方式是如此令人鼓舞，关于那一刻可能意味着什么，以至于——我不想替你做决定，但听起来你对死亡的恐惧已经不像以前那么深了。听了那个故事后，我也感同身受，我并不是在期待那一刻，但我对它的恐惧已经不如从前那么深了。
So to the extent you're comfortable, please. Yeah, for me, I think most people have, I have a different relationship with fear, first and foremost, because I worked on it every day, something I was afraid of for a decade. I just don't have a lot of fear in my life. I certainly wasn't afraid of death, but you can think that and believe that,
所以，只要你觉得舒服，请讲讲吧。好的，对我来说，我觉得大多数人都有……我和恐惧的关系与众不同，首先是因为我每天都在克服恐惧，这是我害怕了十年的事情。我的生活中其实没有太多的恐惧。我当然不害怕死亡，但你可以这么想、这么相信，
but it's a confirmation now. I found there's a lot of confirmations when you're tested to your limits and to your death and come back. There's a lot of confirmations that come out of that. Because I can believe in XYZ, but now there's proof in the pudding. Because I went there. And yeah, the exhilarating peace that happens in leaving this body,
不过现在这得到了证实。我发现当你被逼到极限、濒临死亡又死里逃生时，会得到很多印证。从那以后会产生很多印证。因为我可以相信甲乙丙丁，但现在事实胜于雄辩。因为我去过那里。是的，那种离开这具身体时感受到的令人陶醉的平静，
with these limitations of spinning on this rock and this body with air and gravity, all this bullshit. But when you're, it's an exhilaration and it's such a freedom. So you remember feeling that? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Feeling that, really? Yeah, yeah, and I take that feeling with me all the time now. Wow.
伴随着旋转在这块岩石上的种种局限，带着空气和重力这具身体，以及所有这些狗屁东西。但当你身处其中时，那是一种狂喜，是一种极致的自由。所以你还记得那种感觉吗？哦，对，对，对。真的能感觉到那种感觉？对，对，我现在随时都带着那种感觉。哇。
It's, you can't really put a visual to it because there's no time, place, or space. It's all sort of a continuum. Every human, every exchange that's happened is happening simultaneously all at once. It kind of has a little bit of that arrival kind of vibe in it. Wow. It's like everything's all at once, and it's a little bit of that arrival kind of vibe in it. It's like everything's all at once
这，你很难给它加上一个视觉画面，因为它没有时间、地点或空间。它全都是某种连续体。每一个人、每一次发生过的交流都在同时发生。它有点那种“抵达”的氛围。哇。就像一切都在同时发生，而且有点那种“抵达”的氛围。就像一切都在同时发生，
and it's a continuum and it's fucking exhilarating as it is peaceful at the same time. It's the greatest way I can describe it. Now you really did see the light that everybody talks about, yeah? It's a, yeah, to me it was, it's a sort of fibrous, like a muscle fibrous sort of connectivity to all, it's all energy, right?
它是一个连续体，而且它他妈的既狂喜又平静。这是我能描述它的最好的方式。所以你真的看到了大家都在谈论的那道光，对吧？那是，对，对我来说，它是一种纤维状的，就像肌肉纤维一样与万物相连的东西，全都是能量，对吧？
So I guess that's the feeling that it is. I can't even say it's a visual, because I don't feel like any of that's there. Wow. Now, isn't it true that like, Will, you were telling me something about like, you can recreate, science has discovered a way to create that with certain drugs or circumstances where you can, that same, do you know what I'm talking about?
所以我想这就是那种感觉。我甚至不能说它是一个视觉影像，因为我觉得那些东西都不存在。哇。话说回来，难道不是吗，威尔，你之前跟我说过，比如你可以重现，科学已经发现了一种方法，可以通过某些药物或环境来创造那种体验，你可以……你知道我在说什么吗？
Like that same light or that same thing. Will, were you trying to sell Sean something out of the back of your van at that moment? No, no, I was saying that if you go, you know where, well, there's a guy, J-Rock, I told you about. He's got that DMT hookup. And he's got that DMT, and if you...
就像那道光或者类似的东西。威尔，你当时是想从你的面包车后备箱里向肖恩兜售什么东西吗？不，不，我的意思是，如果你去，你知道在哪儿，有个叫杰罗克的家伙，我跟你提过。他有DMT（二甲基色胺）的货。他有DMT，如果你……
Jay Rock. Jay Rock, he'd go for a weekend. He does a weekend if you take the 118 all the way to the UK. I knew a guy named Earthquake that would sell me some J-Bod. Oh, yeah. And we will be right back. When I say we get support from Helix, boy do I mean it. I get so much support from my mattress from Helix. It's amazing.
杰罗克。杰罗克，他会去过周末。如果你沿着118号公路一直开到英国，他会带你过个周末。我认识一个叫“地震”的家伙，他会卖给我一些J-Bod。哦，对。我们马上回来。当我说是Helix给我们提供赞助时，我是认真的。Helix的床垫给我提供了极大的支撑。这太棒了。
I sleep great. I have the Dusk Lux mattress. I've had it for a few years now and it is beautiful. It's like I get so excited when I climb into bed and I sink right into that beautiful mattress and it just whisks me right off to sleep every single time. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress than by sleeping on it in your own home.
我睡得太好了。我买的是Dusk Lux床垫。我用它好几年了，它简直完美。每当我爬上床时我都激动不已，整个人陷进那张漂亮的床垫里，每一次它都能轻柔地把我带入梦乡。Helix深知测试新床垫的最好方法就是躺在自己家里的床垫上睡上一觉。
Don't sleep on my mattress, sleep on your own Helix mattress. That's why they offer a 100 night trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty. So how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Well, their team created a Helix Sleep Quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes.
别睡我的床垫，去睡你自己的Helix床垫。这就是为什么他们提供100晚的试睡服务以及10到15年的保修。那么，你怎么知道哪款Helix床垫最适合你和你的身体呢？很简单，他们的团队创建了一个Helix睡眠测试，只需不到两分钟就能帮找到你的完美床垫。
And your mattress is shipped straight to your door, free of charge. I took the quiz and got matched with the Desk Lux, as I mentioned, because I wanted that perfect, not too soft, not too firm feel. It's perfect for me. It's like they read my mind. Helix is offering 30% off all mattress orders and
而且床垫会直接免费配送到你的门前。我做了测试，如我所说，匹配到的是Desk Lux，因为我想要那种完美的、既不太软也不太硬的手感。它对我来说完美极了。感觉就像他们读懂了我的心思一样。Helix目前提供所有床垫订单30%的折扣，
two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com SmartList. That's helixsleep.com SmartList. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. We get support from State Farm. Nothing feels better than a personal win, from finishing a home DIY project, hitting a workout PR, or even just taking your car in for that oil change. If you define it as a win, it calls for a celebration.
并且为我们的听众免费提供两个枕头。访问 helixsleep.com 杠 SmartList。也就是 helixsleep.com 杠 SmartList。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了Helix，更优质的睡眠从现在开始。我们感谢State Farm的支持。没有什么比个人的小胜利更美妙的了，比如完成一个家居DIY项目、打破个人健身纪录，甚至是把车送去换机油。如果你把它定义为胜利，那就值得庆祝。
And who's cheering right beside you? State Farm. With the State Farm Personal Price Plan, you can create an affordable price just for you when you bundle home and auto. So celebrate by breaking out the confetti and those happy dance moves. Talk to a State Farm agent today to learn how you can bundle
谁在旁边为你欢呼？State Farm。有了State Farm个人价格计划，当你把房屋和汽车保险打包购买时，就可以为你量身定制一个实惠的价格。所以，抛洒彩纸，跳起快乐的舞蹈来庆祝吧。今天就联系State Farm的保险代理人，了解如何打包
and save with the personal price plan. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Prices are based on rating plans that vary by state. Coverage options are selected by the customer. Availability, amount of discounts and savings, and eligibility vary by state. We'd like to thank FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartList.
并通过个人价格计划省钱。就像好邻居一样，State Farm时刻陪伴在你身边。价格基于因州而异的评级计划。保障选项由客户自主选择。可用性、折扣和节省金额以及资格因州而异。我们要感谢FanDuel对本期SmartList节目的支持。
Summertime means baseball, the NBA Finals, and more, and you can bet it all on FanDuel. Right now, new customers get $200 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's $200 you can use to bet everything from the Finals MVP to who's going to hit one out of the park. I have a friend that uses FanDuel all the time and he raves about it and wins a lot, actually. Visit FanDuel.com slash SmartList and add a big win to your summer bucket list. FanDuel, America's number one sports book. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer.
夏天意味着棒球、NBA总决赛等等，你可以在FanDuel上对这一切下注。现在，新客户只要任意赢得一个5美元的投注，就能获得200美元的奖金投注。这200美元你可以用来下注任何内容，从总决赛MVP到谁能打出本垒打。我有个朋友经常使用FanDuel，他对它赞不绝口，而且实际上赢了不少钱。访问 FanDuel.com 杠 SmartList，为你的夏日愿望清单添上一场大胜。FanDuel，全美排名第一的体育博彩公司。21岁及以上，受条款约束。请查阅节目说明了解完整的免责声明。
SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds, new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audiobooks, podcasts,
SmartList部分内容由Audible为您呈现。在Audible上听书能让你的想象力尽情驰骋。无论你听的是故事、励志内容、专家建议，还是你喜爱的任何流派，你都能被启发去想象新的世界、新的可能性、新的思维方式。找到你喜爱的类型，并在过程中发现新的好书。探索畅销书、新书上架，以及数千部包含在内的有声书、播客，
and originals that members can listen to all they want with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time. There's more to imagine when you listen. Right now I am about to listen to Survive the Night by Riley Sager. It's a thriller that's a real page-turner that's all I want to say about it. I don't want to give anything away but it's
以及会员可以无限畅听的原创内容，并且不断有新内容加入。Audible让你在日常生活中轻松获得灵感和娱乐，无需特意腾出额外时间。当你聆听时，有更多的想象空间。此刻我正准备听雷利·斯格尔（Riley Sager）的《逃离黑夜》（Survive the Night）。这是一部让人爱不释手的惊悚小说，我只想说这么多。我不想剧透，但它
really really good. As an Audible member you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try Audible free for 30 days.
真的非常非常棒。作为Audible会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中选择一本图书永久保留，包括最新畅销书和新书。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问 audible.com 杠 smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500。即 audible.com 杠 smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500 来免费试用Audible 30天。
Audible.com slash smartless. And back to the show. Jeremy, in all seriousness, you know, that is, thank you for sharing that. Yeah, that's really fascinating. Because that reminded me of some of the specifics of what you were saying there. And it is, you know, I don't know if encouraging
Audible.com 杠 smartless。言归正传。杰瑞米，说真的，你知道的，谢谢你分享这些。是的，这真的很迷人。因为这让我想起了你刚才所说的一些细节。而且，你知道的，我不知道“鼓舞人心”是不是合适的词，但它确实向我证实了一些我希望那一刻能呈现的面貌。
is the right word, but it does confirm for me some of the things I hope that moment is. Well, you have to understand too, this, right? Your body, like the accident, right? It could be the most excruciating pain that someone could go through, right? There's 38 broken bones, my eyeballs out of my head, I'm looking at my eye, I'm looking at my twisted legs,
好吧，你也得明白这一点，对吧？你的身体，就像那场事故一样，对吧？那可能是人所能经历的极致痛苦，对吧？有38处骨折，眼球都脱眶了，我看着自己的眼睛，看着自己扭曲的腿，
and all these things, but I'm like, the pain is like really not that bad, your body kind of shuts it down, it's like overload, right? It's just a small part in the front of your brain where you feel pain, right? So you can kind of control that as well. And so it's interesting, fuck I got lost because I got so many issues from that accident in my brain,
以及所有这些情况，但我心想，痛苦其实真的没那么糟，你的身体会把它关闭，这就像是超载，对吧？你感受到痛觉的其实只是大脑前部的一小块区域，对吧？所以你也可以在某种程度上控制它。所以这很有趣，他妈的我讲偏题了，因为那场事故给我脑子留下了太多问题，
I get a little sad track. Well so the pain is overwhelming, but the brain then has, it shuts that down, but it is also still working and has an opportunity to experience the other stuff that you're going through, which it sounds like this was the big thing that it chose to deal with, which was this opportunity to transition to whatever
我有点走神了。好吧，所以痛苦是压倒性的，但大脑随后会将其关闭，不过大脑此时仍在运转，并且有机会体验你正在经历的其他事情，听起来这正是它选择处理的大事件，也就是这个过渡到身体停止运转后所发生的一切的机会，你正在体验那一刻是怎样的。你还记得当时自己有权做出决定吗？你能控制自己是继续向前还是返回吗？我的意思是，我能控制我的呼吸。
happens after the body stops working anymore, and you're sort of experiencing what that moment is. And do you remember having a decision to make? Were you in control of whether you were going to go forward or return back? I mean, I was in control of my breath. And that's all I had to focus on, because if you can't breathe,
这就是我当时唯一需要关注的，因为如果你不能呼吸，
then nothing else is gonna matter. So I had to focus on exhaling, so I could then inhale, and I had a popped lung and all this stuff I didn't know. And the thing's still on top of you right then, right? No, I was, it rolled completely over me. And then it, yeah. Wow. Yeah, it was brutal.
其他一切就都不重要了。所以我必须专注于呼气，然后才能吸气，当时我有一侧肺破了，还有各种我当时并不知道的伤情。那个东西当时还压在你身上吗？没有，它完全从我身上碾过去了。然后它，对。哇。对，太惨烈了。
Right. But, yeah, just conscious breath. Conscious breath was pretty important. And, you know, like you said, there's nothing to freaking worry about at the end of the day, you know, and I can confirm that. We all have something to look forward to. Whether we use God to get there, right, or whatever it is,
对。但是，对吧，只有有意识的呼吸。有意识的呼吸非常重要。而且，就像你说的，到了最后关头，根本没什么好担心的，你知道的，我向大家证实这一点。我们都有值得期待的事。不管我们是借助上帝到达那里，对吧，还是别的什么，
but it's something to look forward to and it's blissful and it's beautiful and there's accountability and responsibility that comes along with it and you take it all with you, man. Everything, everything. You're connected, you're connected all the time to all you want to be connected to. To everyone on this planet.
但那确实是值得期待的事情，而且它是极乐的、美好的，其中伴随着问责与责任，你会把这一切全部带走，伙计。一切，一切。你是相连的，你始终与所有你想连接的人相连。与这个星球上的每个人相连。
Yeah, yeah, it is all one thing, it's no fucking joke. It's all energy. Jeremy, did you have, I mean, this shift in perspective is remarkable, I'm sure, and I can see the weight of it, and I can't appreciate it the way that you can, obviously, but has this, I imagine, and you kind of touched on it, but talk a little bit about what that shift in perspective has done for you in practical terms on a day-to-day level? Yeah, I think the clarity. I think everyone is conspiring to keep my life lean and keep the white noise out.
对，对，这全都是一体的，真的一点都不开玩笑。这全都是能量。杰瑞米，你有没有……我的意思是，这种视角的变化非常显著，我确信，我能看出它的分量，虽然我无法像你那样深刻地体会到这一点，但我想象一下——你也稍微提到过这一点——能简单谈谈这种视角的变化在日常的实际层面上给你带来了什么改变吗？对，我认为是清晰度。我觉得每个人都在合力让我的生活保持精简，把杂音排除在外。
I feel that life is a lot easier, even though on paper it's much more difficult to spend hours just so I can walk every day. You know, I have to do all this stuff. Still? Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I'm in good shape, but I don't have pain. I have to do just a bunch of stuff, and who cares? I'm still walking, right?
我觉得生活变得轻松多了，尽管在纸面上看，为了每天能走路而花上好几个小时其实要困难得多。你知道的，我必须做所有这些事情。现在还要吗？对，对，对。但我状态很好，而且我不痛了。我只是需要做一堆事情，那又怎样？我还是能走路，对吧？
They told me I wasn't gonna walk, but I think my life being so lean, and it's been the best gift. Yeah, imagine you don't sweat the small stuff anymore. No, yeah, it wasn't really a guy that did, but again, it's one of those sort of confirmation kind of things. It's like the things that were working for me before,
他们曾告诉我我无法走路，但我认为我的生活变得如此精简，这真的是最好的礼物。对，可以想象你不再为什么小事纠结了。不，对，我本来就不是那种会纠结的人，但再次强调，这就像是那种得到印证的事情。就像那些以前对我有用的事情，
I really just doubled down on. And whether it's spending time with those, it's like you, Jason, how much you love your family and want to spend time with your family, and whatever it is, you just do the things that you love to do. And I was really terrible at doing stuff for myself and asking for help.
我真的只是加倍坚持了它们。不管是花时间陪伴那些人——就像你一样，杰森，你有多么爱你的家人并想花时间陪伴家人，无论是什么，你只是去做那些你热爱的事。而我以前很不擅长为自己做事情以及向别人寻求帮助。
Now I'm really good at asking for help because Jesus Christ, I needed all the help I can get. And then so I have no problem asking for help and I spend so much time on myself and self care. I'm like, look, I've got hydrogen water, I've got all these shots, I've got liposomal, even right here. I've got all this stuff,
现在我非常擅长寻求帮助，因为天呐，我太需要所有我能得到的帮助了。所以我在寻求帮助方面没有任何问题，我花大量的时间在自己身上和自我关怀上。我心想，看，我有氢水，我有各种营养注射剂，我有脂质体，甚至就在这里。我有所有这些东西，
I'm doing so many good things for my body. So I honor this vessel that I'm living in right now. Like life is just wonderful, because again, it's so clean and simple. And I love that. Sean feels the same. Sean, you got a lot of help from the Frito Lay Company. They do a lot of work with you.
我为自己的身体做了那么多好事。所以我尊重我目前居住的这副躯壳。生活简直太美妙了，因为再次说明，它是如此纯粹和简单。我太喜欢这样了。肖恩也有同感。肖恩，你从菲多利公司得到了很多帮助。他们跟你有很多合作。
Well, they know what I need. They make the bags a little bit easier to open nowadays. The McConnell Ice Cream Company also is one of your guys. Haagen-Dazs, Haagen-Dazs. Haagen-Dazs, sure. But Jerry, you know what? The whole thing, such an inspiration to never give up, to keep going, to take the worst things in life
好吧，他们知道我需要什么。他们现在把袋子做得更容易打开了。麦康奈尔冰淇淋公司也是你们的人。哈根达斯，哈根达斯。哈根达斯，没错。但杰瑞米，你知道吗？整件事，真的是一个巨大的激励，告诉我们永远不要放弃，要坚持下去，把生活中遇到的最糟糕的事情，
that come after you when you come out on top. All of it, I mean, really, I saw that video, I was like, God, if he can come through that, I gotta get off my ass and just take better self off my vessel. Well, you will one day. Jeremy, talk a little bit, if you will, about, because you kind of mentioned it about this creative,
那些向你袭来的打击，当你挺过来时，你成了赢家。这一切，我的意思是，真的，我看到那个视频时心想，天哪，如果他能挺过这一切，我也得赶快从屁股底下挪开，好好照顾我的这副躯壳。好吧，你总有一天会的。杰瑞米，如果可以的话，能稍微聊聊关于——因为你刚才提到了这种创造力，
this sort of, we're all connected the the sort of Collective consciousness that is a lot more sort of real and visceral than we think and rather just an idea and your relationship with Maybe God even or higher power or whatever that is Where do you land on all that stuff and you guys too? I don't know Yeah, well my dad is a theologist, and so I studied all religions growing up. Oh wow, that's cool, I love that. I've been in tents with snakes, and I've been in all of them, studied them all.
这种，我们都是相连的，这种集体意识比我们想象的要真实和直觉得多，它不仅仅是一个概念——你与上帝甚至更高力量（无论那是什么）的关系，你对所有这些事情是怎么看的？你们呢？我不知道。对，我爸爸是个神学家，所以我从小就研究所有宗教。哦，哇，太酷了，我很喜欢。我进过装满蛇的帐篷，我体验过所有这些，把它们都研究了一遍。
And I found them all interesting. Organized religions never end up being my bag, but I think because of it. But I do believe that in anything that, believe in anything that makes you a better person, a more thoughtful person, a conscious person, I think that's great. So I've got no problems with religion in general. So I land, look, at some point during my recovery, I know I had to give up my body to the EMTs and the people when I was on the ice
我发现它们都很有趣。有组织宗教从来不是我的菜，但我想正是因为这个原因。不过我相信，任何能让你成为一个更好的人、一个更有思想的人、一个有意识的人的事物，我都觉得那很好。所以我对宗教本身没有任何意见。所以我的看法是，听吧，在我康复的某个阶段，我知道当我躺在冰面上45分钟时，我必须把自己的身体交给急救人员和其他人，
for 45 minutes, right? Just struggling for my next breath and that's where I passed and they had to jam a needle in my chest and do all that stuff, inflate my lung. I gave myself up to them to just have to work on whatever they had to do to get me to survive. But I think there's all because also those I knew the guy that that was working on me and he called one of my best friends
苦苦挣扎着寻找下一次呼吸，那正是我一度离世的时候，他们不得不把针头扎进我的胸口，做所有这些事情，给我的肺充气。我把自己交托给他们，让他们去做他们必须做的一切来让我活下来。但我认为这一切之所以发生，也是因为我知道那个抢救我的人，他给我的一位消防员挚友打了电话，他说你最好赶快去医院，因为我刚坐医疗直升机飞往医院了，
who's a firefighter he says you're gonna want to get to the hospital because I just took off in a med effect flight to the to the hospital and he called my buddy who's a firefighter he's like I just worked on Jeremy Dada's want to see we did the best we could and he's like there's no way this worker's gonna make it. So he went to the hospital, said he wanted to get there, go be with his sister, whatever. And you know, when those guys say, you don't have a chance, right?
他给我那个当消防员的朋友打电话说：我刚抢救了杰瑞米，你可能想来看看，我们尽力了。他说这哥们儿活下来的几率微乎其微。所以他去了医院，说他想去那里，去陪他妹妹，诸如此类的。你知道的，当那些急救人员说你没机会的时候，对吧？
So I think there's some fucking divine intervention is the shortest. I don't know what it is, guys. I don't know, there is no answer to that. I think the divine intervention is fucking thoughts and prayers, if you will, from others. It's the will of those doctors, they're like, look at this motherfucker.
所以我认为这其中一定有什么他妈的神圣干预，简单来说。我不知道那是什么，伙计们。我不知道，这没有答案。我认为所谓的神圣干预，他妈的就是别人的想法和祈祷（如果你愿意这么叫的话）。那是那些医生的意志，他们心想：看看这个杂种，
We're gonna work extra hard. Or die, whatever the, like, my will, right? My will is fucking, it's strong, let me just say that. And I think there's others, that energy goes into others that would help, all those EMTs and the firefighters that were there saving my ass, and Sheriff Department, all those guys that were there to save my ass, right?
我们得加倍努力。或者死路一条，无论那是什么，比如我的意志，对吧？我的意志他妈的非常坚定，我只能这么说。我认为还有其他人的意志，这种能量进入了其他人身上并提供了帮助，所有那些在现场拯救我屁股的急救人员和消防员，还有警长部门，所有那些去拯救我屁股的家伙，对吧？
All connected. Yeah, it's all connected, man. So as hard as I was working, I think that bleeds into others and they worked harder, and I think every flower that came in, every nurse that changed a bit, whatever the heck it is, man, that's all like love and all working towards surviving. And let that be divine, the collective divinity of humans, right, which I think is fucking brilliant and good,
全都是相连的。对，全都是相连的，伙计。所以尽管我一直在努力，但我认为这会感染到其他人，让他们也加倍努力，我认为送来的每一束花、每一个换绷带的护士，不管到底是什么，伙计，那全都是爱，全都在为了生存而努力。让这成为神圣的力量吧，人类集体的神圣性，对吧？我觉得这他妈的太棒、太美好了，
the energy of human. Yes, I agree. And I think that's what the divine intervention is, ultimately. I don't think it's what the divine intervention is, ultimately. I don't think it's some god or some guy coming down on a carpet or whatever. It's none of these kind of things. I just think it's an energetic thing. And I can define it as love. That's maybe what divine intervention is for me.
人类的能量。是的，我同意。我想这才是神圣干预的终极含义。我不认为那是什么上帝或某个坐在飞毯上降临的家伙之类的。根本不是这些乱七八糟的东西。我只是觉得这是一种能量层面的东西。我可以把它定义为爱。这或许就是对我而言的神圣干预。
That helps me survive. I think that fucking continues. Us just sitting here talking about it, I'm sure thoughts of thoughts are swirling in all of our heads as we're talking, right? Yeah, you make me think about what an incredible opportunity everybody has to plug into that network of connectivity. 100%, yes.
这帮助我活了下来。我认为这种东西一直在延续。我们坐在这里谈论它，我确信当我们交谈时，各种想法也在我们所有人脑海中盘旋，对吧？对，你让我想到每个人都有多么不可思议的机会去接入那个连接网络。百分之百，是的。
Where it is available to all of us, and it is labeled different things at different times. Sometimes it's love, sometimes it's religion, sometimes it's collaboration, whatever you want to call it. But we're all here and we all kind of come from the same thing. And that whole sort of one plus one makes three equation is again, it's available to us all. And sometimes I have days where I've got the courage
它对我们所有人都是开放的，而且在不同时期被贴上了不同的标签。有时它是爱，有时它是宗教，有时它是协作，随你想怎么称呼它。但我们都在这里，我们都源自同一样东西。而“一加一等于三”这个等式再次证明，它对我们所有人都是可用的。有时我也会有这样的日子，我有勇气
to plug into it and leave myself open to the input from other people. And some days I don't, you know? And the days that I do have that courage and that openness and that vulnerability and that humanity sort of draw, those days are great for me. And things, you just feel like you're in a slot
接入那个网络，让自己向其他人的输入敞开心扉。而有时我没有，你知道吗？而当我拥有那种勇气、那种开放性、那种脆弱感和人性的吸引力时，那些日子对我来说就棒极了。事情会变得很顺，
and shit just happens. You get the parking spot in front of the building you're going to, you make the green light, like all of that silly stuff, but I don't think that's coincidence. I think those are the days when you're really open to this community. You know, I agree.
你刚好能把车停在你去的建筑门前，一路上全是绿灯，所有这些看似愚蠢的小事，但我认为这不是巧合。我认为那正是你真正向这个群体敞开心扉的日子。你知道，我同意。
But JB, there's also the idea, there's an idea to, first of all, I love plugging into a slot, but I would say, that's just OCD, but I would say this, I would say, you know, those days when it also, for me anyway, my experience is, it's really important to, whatever energy I'm putting out there, whatever I'm putting in the world, I'm gonna get back.
但JB，还有另一个观点，首先，我很喜欢接入那个网络的感觉——但我得说，那只是强迫症——不过我要说的是，你知道，那些日子里，对我们来说也是一样，我的经验是，非常重要的一点是，无论我释放出什么能量，无论我把什么带进这个世界，我都会得到回报。
And what you were saying, like, fighting the open spot or whatever, if I'm driving on the highway, or if I'm driving around Los Angeles, I'm going, look at this asshole and fuck this guy, and whatever, every asshole is gonna show up in my experience. But if I surrender, and there's a lot of surrender
就像你刚才说的，去争抢一个空车位之类的，如果我在高速公路上开着车，或者在洛杉矶开车，然后我心里想：看看这个混蛋，去他妈的这人，诸如此类的，那么每一个混蛋都会出现在我的经历里。但如果我臣服——你刚才所说的内容里包含着大量的臣服，
in what you're talking about, Jeremy, throughout everything you've said, there's a lot of surrender and giving up. And if I surrender and go, I'm not in that much of a rush. It's not gonna make that much, let the guy go ahead of me. And then you know what starts happening? Everything starts opening up. Because if I keep going fuck, fuck, fuck,
杰瑞米，在你所说的一切当中，有很多关于臣服与放下的内容。如果我臣服并心想：我没那么赶时间。这其实没那么大不了，让那家伙开到我前面去吧。然后你知道会发生什么吗？一切都开始豁然开朗了。因为如果我一直“操、操、操”地骂个不停，
and eventually somebody's giving me the finger on the 405. Guaranteed, that's a lock. But if I start just opening up and just going, taking my foot off the gas and surrendering, and that goes for every aspect of my life. I find it all the time. I try to do it in little things, it's not easy. I call it like sort of spiritual calisthenics.
最终肯定会有人在405号公路上对我竖中指。这是绝对的，百分之百会发生。但如果我开始敞开心扉，心想，把脚从油门上拿开并选择臣服，这适用于我生活的方方面面。我一直在实践这一点。我试着在小事上做到这一点，这并不容易。我称之为某种精神上的健身操。
Just doing things, I'm just putting out good vibes as much as I can. Sometimes I'll just show up to your house and give you the finger, like when you answer the door. Yeah, one time Shum woke me up in the middle of the night, shaking me, I opened my eyes, and he was just giving me the finger, and he said, fuck you.
只是去做一些事情，尽可能地释放出好的正能量。有时我甚至会直接出现在你家门口，然后对你竖中指，比如当你开门的时候。对，有一次肖恩在半夜把我摇醒，把我晃醒，我睁开眼睛，他正冲我竖中指，然后他说：去你妈的。
Yeah, that's helpful. I love that visual. But you know what I mean? I think that there's a lot to that, and I'm feeling like the energy, again, not to sound too fricking hokey, people are gonna be like, hey, but you can feel it. You've got this kind of vibe that you're putting out there
对，这真有帮助。我喜欢这个画面。但你知道我的意思吗？我觉得这里面大有学门，我觉得那种能量——再次强调，听起来可能有点太他妈虚无缥缈了，人们可能会想：嘿——但你真的能感觉得到。你散发出的那种氛围
which is sort of a loving positive vibe. So it's no surprise that that's what showed up in your experience. And now does that translate into like how you approach, sorry to get back to this stuff, but how you approach work now? Or is it still the same? Well, I think it's, I was very terrified, you know, I was very terrified to get,
是一种充满爱的积极氛围。所以，这种氛围投射到你的经历中也就不足为奇了。现在，这是否转化为了你对待工作的方式？抱歉又回到这个话题上，但这是否改变了你现在对待工作的方式？还是说依然和以前一样？好吧，我觉得，我以前非常害怕，你知道的，我非常害怕去接触，
because I'm, to do like fucking fiction? I mean, I'm still trying to live in reality. I'm trying to live, right? So it was, it was a hard line for me to cross. Because shit got real and then your job is to be fake. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's like, wow, man. It was a big stretch.
因为要去演他妈的虚构故事？我的意思是，我还在努力过着真实的生活。我正在努力活着，对吧？所以，对我来说，这是一条很难跨越的界限。因为生活变得如此真实，而你的工作却是去假装。对，对，对。所以感觉就像，哇，伙计。这真是一次巨大的跨越。
It was very, very challenging for me, mentally, to get over that hump. And I still struggle with it sometimes. It was a big stretch. It was very challenging for me mentally to get over that hump. And I still struggle with it sometimes. I don't take it super seriously. I'm in a character that I can do very well and I know the show very well, so it was easy for me to kind of slide back into it.
对我来说，从精神上迈过这个坎真的非常非常艰难。而且我现在有时还在与它做斗争。这跨度太大了。从精神上迈过这个坎对我有很大的挑战。而且有时我还在为此挣扎。我没有把它看得太严肃。我扮演的角色我能驾驭得很好，我也很了解这个节目，所以对我来说重新进入状态比较容易。
But if it was a very challenging role, I couldn't have taken it. Not challenging in the sense of, because this movie, the show's challenging, but it's that, you know, if I had to go play Dahmer or something, like something so far from me. Like the spiritual space. Yeah, I just don't have the energy for it.
但如果这是一个极具挑战性的角色，我就接不了了。这里的挑战不是指那种……因为这部电影、这个节目本身就很有挑战，而是说，如果我要去演达摩（Dahmer）或者类似的角色，那种离我太远的角色。比如精神层面上的。对，我只是没有那种精力。
I don't have the fuel. I have so much fuel to put into like this reality, this body, all this stuff. I can't just go play make believe right now. Because it takes a lot of time to get right here every day, just so I can have a positive thought, so I can progress, so I can always keep growing. Well, listen to me, you need to write books, because I'd read...
我没有那种动力。我有太多的动力要投入到这个现实、这个身体、所有这些事情中去。我现在不能去玩过家家。因为每天要调整到这个状态需要花很多时间，只有这样我才能有一个积极的想法，才能取得进展，才能一直不断成长。听着，你真该写本书，因为我会去读……
I am writing one right now, actually. Oh, you are? I'm writing one right now, and I'm going to spend the whole summer doing it. Hopefully I can get it out Maybe by the year's end or beginning next year amazing but you know having experiences like this, you know, I speak to a lot of different people but Always something new comes out and always learn something new in in the process and the questions Yeah, and it seems like you really light up when you talk about this
其实我正在写一本。哦，是吗？我正在写一本，我打算整个夏天都用来写。希望能在今年底或明年初把它出版。太棒了。但你知道，有过这样的经历，你知道的，我和很多人交流过，在这个过程中总会有新的东西出现，也总能学到新的东西，还有那些问题。是的，而且听你谈起这些时，你整个人都在发光。
Which again like you said is it's part of the gift of that happening. Yeah, it's a wonderful gift. You said it was the best thing that's ever happened to you. Yeah, yeah, it's wonderful gifts. And it'll be, you know, something Palson will have with you guys forever, right? Our exchanges will always have a basis of this, a wink to the knowingness of something, right? And we can laugh at all the jokes we want
就像你说的，这也是那次经历带来的礼物的一部分。是的，这是一份美妙的礼物。你说这是你经历过的最好的事情。是的，是的，这是美妙的礼物。而且你知道，这将是帕尔森（Palson）和你们永远拥有的东西，对吧？我们的交流将永远以这个为基础，带着对某种事物的会心微笑，对吧？我们可以随心所欲地开各种玩笑
and fart and do all, you know, go play golf terribly, and whatever it is, but we know there's an underlying current of a connectivity to something. Yes. And it's something beautiful about it. Yeah, and you've had that experience firsthand, and you have very, very generously shared that
然后放屁，做各种事，你知道的，去打一场糟糕的高尔夫，无论什么都行，但我们知道其中暗含着与某种事物的连结。是的。这其中有一种美妙的东西。是的，你亲身经历了这种体验，而且你非常非常慷慨地与我们分享了这些
with not only us, but the people listening. And if they're like me, they will hold onto it forever. Because our mortality is something that we can kind of compartmentalize for a while, but if you're on the second half, like us guys are, it starts to become a little bit more a part of your thinking day to day. And you've given me a lot more comfort
不仅是与我们，还有听众们。如果他们像我一样，会永远铭记在心。因为我们的生死问题，我们一段时间内可以把它存放在心里的某个角落，但如果你到了后半生，就像我们这些家伙一样，它开始更多地成为你日常思考的一部分。你给了我更多的慰藉
for what the inevitable is. And I really, really appreciate that. Yeah, man. Yeah, and Jeremy, I really mean it. It sounds cheesy to say it, but thanks for the lessons today. And I mean that. I'm like, wow, I mean, all the stuff
对于不可避免的结局。我真的很感激。是的，老兄。是的，杰里，我是认真的。说这话听起来可能有点老套，但谢谢你今天的教导。我是真心这么觉得。我当时想，哇，我是说你谈到的所有这些事情
that you're talking about, I'm now gonna be, like you said, I'm gonna be thinking about it for the rest of my life. Because there's, people say the same things in different ways, but they don't land all the stuff that you're talking about, I'm now gonna be, like you said, I'm gonna be thinking about it for the rest of my life. Because people say the same things in different ways, but they don't land all the time. And a lot of the stuff you said today really landed. Well, thanks, brother. That just means it's just a shared experience then.
正如你所说，接下来的余生我都会一直在思考。因为人们会用不同的方式表达同样的事情，但并不是每一次都能触动人心。你今天说的很多话真的深深触动了我。谢谢你，兄弟。那说明这只是一种共同的经历。
Right, this is not a lesson. These are just shared experiences. Yeah, I love this sort of the shift in perspective. It's pretty amazing. And as somebody once said, it's really hard to get a new perspective if you can't get perspective. Like it's like if you can't just allow yourself
对，这不是什么教导。这只是一种共同的经历。是的，我很喜欢这种视角上的转变。这太奇妙了。正如某人曾经说过的那样，如果你无法获得视角，就很难获得新的视角。这就像如果你不允许自己去拥有它
to have it, it's hard to get it. And anyway, I really feel it from you, man. It's fucking awesome. And before you go, please do another, do a sequel to Arrival, please. Yeah. It's called Departure. Yeah. That's called Departure.
去体验它，那就很难得到它。总之，我真的从你身上感受到了，老兄。这太棒了。在你走之前，请拍一部续集，给《降临》拍个续集吧。好。叫《离开》。对。就叫《离开》。
That's really funny. Jeremy, thank you so, so much for your time today and your level of transparency with what your experience has been. It's been a real gift, so thank you, buddy. Yeah, man. I love you guys, man. Appreciate the time. Love you too, Jeremy. You too, brother. Well done, man. Fucking killer. Thanks, pal. Hope I see you soon, buddy. Yeah, man, I love you guys, man. Appreciate the time. Love you too, Jeremy. You too, brother. Well done, man. Fucking killer.
太好笑了。杰里，非常非常感谢你今天抽出时间，以及你对自己的经历表现出的坦诚。这真的是一份厚礼，所以谢谢你，伙计。是的，老兄。我爱你们，伙计们。感谢你们的时间。我也爱你们，杰里。你也是，兄弟。干得好，老兄。太牛了。谢谢，伙计。希望不久能见到你，伙计。是的，老兄，我爱你们，伙计们。感谢你们的时间。我也爱你们，杰里。你也是，兄弟。干得好，老兄。太牛了。
Thanks, pal. Hope I see you soon, pal. Yes, sir. Thanks, Jeremy. Have a good day. See you, man. Thank you, dude. All right, man, man. Bye, buddy. See you, guys.
谢谢，伙计。希望不久能见到你，伙计。没问题，先生。谢谢，杰里。祝你有美好的一天。再见，老兄。谢谢你，伙计。好的，老兄，老兄。再见，伙计。再见，伙计们。
Well, I hope... Enlightening. Yeah, I hope that story... I mean, the whole interview was really enjoyable, but man, I just can't tell you how I have held on to that, what he told me at dinner, and I'm so appreciative that he shared it with all of us today, because if you're like me,
好吧，我希望……很有启发性。是的，我希望那个故事……我是说，整个采访过程非常愉快，但老兄，我真的无法形容我是多么深刻地记住了他在晚宴上对我说的话，我非常感激他今天能和我们所有人分享这些，因为如果你和我一样，
it's kind of, it's just sort of a nice thing to have in your back, you're in your pocket that it might not. If you see that train coming. Well, I mean, it's gonna happen to all of us. Everything that's born lives to, or what is it, everything that lives was born to die, something like that, I think it's a Pink Floyd line,
这就像是，把它揣在兜里、放在背后总是一件挺好的事，以防万一。如果你看到那辆火车开过来。我是说，这终将发生在我们所有人身上。所有活着的东西生来就是为了……或者怎么说来着，所有活着的东西生来就是为了死去，诸如此类，我想这是平克·弗洛伊德（Pink Floyd）的一句歌词，
but we're all going. And what is that moment like? I hope it's not terrible, I hope it's not sad, I hope it's not painful, it sounds like it's not. Yeah. Shit. Yeah, shit. I got some fucking bad.
但我们终将离去。那一刻会是什么样的？我希望它不是可怕的，我希望它不是悲伤的，我希望它不是痛苦的，听起来它并不是。是的。操。是的，操。我遇到了一些该死的麻烦。
I'm ready. Okay, I know how both you guys die. What? Uh-oh, what, how do you know? Is it painful? It's interesting, it is a little painful. How do you know this? Have you ever seen, okay, have you, because I just did, okay, you remember the movie,
我准备好了。好吧，我知道你们俩是怎么死的。什么？呃，什么，你怎么知道的？这很痛苦吗？有趣的是，这确实有点痛苦。你怎么知道的？你有没有看过，好吧，你有没有，因为我刚刚看过了，好吧，你还记得那部电影吗，
you know that story about that Chilean rugby team? Sure, sure, yeah. So you guys are, fuck, it's so crazy. Anyway, you guys end up shit-racked. You and Sean, the two of you. Shit-racked? Fucking Sean eats you, dude. What?
你知道关于那支智利橄榄球队的故事吗？当然，当然，是的。所以你们俩，操，太疯狂了。总之，你们俩最后烂透了。你和肖恩，你们两个。烂透了？他妈的肖恩把你给吃了，伙计。什么？
Does he season me at all? You guys get shit-wrecked and it's just the two of you in a big container of mayo. But if I eat Jason, well, how do I die? Well, you die because... But if I eat Jason will how do I die well Because no because yeah, because it's he's so malnourished He's still malnourished That it that it ends up poisoning you Nutritional value at all to my body body goes into a shock. So jokes on me.
他吃我之前给我调味了吗？你们俩完蛋了，现场只剩下大桶蛋黄酱里的你们俩。那如果我吃杰森，好吧，那我怎么死的？好吧，你死是因为……但如果我吃杰森，我怎么死的，好吧，因为，不，因为，是的，因为他太营养不良了，他太营养不良了，以至于最后把你给毒死了。对我的身体没有任何营养价值，身体进入了休克状态。所以倒霉的是我。
Well, I just want to say about Jerry, he was so great. He's a perfect example of following your heart and good things happen, period. You know? Just like, I love that. He's such a good guy. Yeah, he really is. And honestly, it is true. When you hear him, this is what we've talked about before,
好吧，我只想说关于杰瑞的事，他太棒了。他是听从内心、然后好事发生的一个完美例子，就这么简单。你知道吗？就像，我太喜欢这个了。他是个这么好的人。是的，他真的是。老实说，确实如此。当你听他说话时，这正是我们之前讨论过的，
which is he's clearly had a shift in like, what validates him as a person is not about what he does for a living, but who he is as a person. And he can separate those things. And it's so true, and because it's so easy, especially doing what we do, to peg your feeling of success or success as a human being to what you do. And that that is your wealth. Yeah, what he's saying.
也就是他显然经历了一种心态转变，即什么能证明他作为个人的价值，不再取决于他以什么为生，而取决于他是一个怎样的人。他能把这两者区分开来。这太真实了，因为特别是在我们这一行，非常容易把你的成功感或作为人的价值与你的工作挂钩，并认为那就是你的财富。是的，他所说的。
No, no, the wealth is the... And it's not, it's not. It's the living, it's the relationships that you have with other people. And he said that that connection with other people is really the thing that got him through. So that's pretty amazing. Well, that was a nice episode, y'all.
不，不，财富是……并不是，根本不是。财富是生活，是你与其他人的关系。他说，与他人的这种连结才是真正带他度过难关的东西。所以这真的很神奇。好吧，各位，那是个不错的单集。
Yeah, really nice. It was real nice. I'm sorry to learn that my life comes to an end with Sean taking a big byeeeeee out of me. Byeeeeee! Byeeeeee! Smart. Lens.
是的，真的很好。真的很棒。听到我的生命最终以肖恩从我身上狠狠咬下一大块而告终，我感到很遗憾。拜拜——！拜拜——！聪明。镜头。
Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. SmartLess
聪明。镜头。聪明。镜头。聪明。镜头。聪明。镜头。聪明。镜头。SmartLess 是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔马亚尔（Rob Armjarf）和班尼特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）100% 有机手工制作的。SmartLess
If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. It's all a lighthearted nightmare on our podcast, Morbid. We're your hosts. I'm Alina Urquhart. And I'm Ash Kelly. And our show is part true crime, part spooky, Morbid. We're your hosts, I'm Alina Urquhart. And I'm Ash Kelly. And our show is part true crime, part spooky, and part comedy. The stories we cover are well researched.
如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以通过在 Wondry 应用中或在苹果播客上加入 Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告版本。在你离开之前，请在 Wondry.com/survey 填写简短的问卷，向我们介绍一下你自己。在我们的播客《莫比德》（Morbid）中，一切都是一场轻松的噩梦。我是你们的主持人阿丽娜·厄克特（Alina Urquhart）。我是阿什·凯利（Ash Kelly）。我们的节目部分关于真实罪案，部分诡异惊悚，《莫比德》。我是你们的主持人，我是阿丽娜·厄克特。我是阿什·凯利。我们的节目部分关于真实罪案，部分诡异惊悚，还带点喜剧色彩。我们涵盖的故事都经过了充分的调查研究。
He claimed and confessed to officially killing up to 28 people. With a touch of humor. I just like to go ahead and say that if there's no band called Malevolent Deity, that is pretty great. A dash of sarcasm and just garnished a bit with a little bit of cursing. This mother-f***er lied. Like a liar. Like a liar. And if you're a weirdo like us and love to cozy up to a creepy tale of the paranormal.
他声称并供认了多起杀人案，最多达 28 人。带有一点幽默感。我想先说一句，如果没有一支乐队叫“恶意神明（Malevolent Deity）”，那真是太可惜了。带有一点讽刺意味，再配上一点点脏话。这个王八蛋撒谎了。就像个骗子一样。像个骗子一样。如果你也像我们一样是个怪咖，喜欢依偎在超自然现象的恐怖故事里。
Or you love to hop in the way back machine and dissect the details of some of history's most notorious crimes. You should tune in to our podcast, Morbid. Follow Morbid on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can tune in to our podcast, Morbid. Follow Morbid on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts.
或者你喜欢坐上时光机器，剖析历史上一些最臭名昭著的犯罪细节。你应该收听我们的播客《莫比德》。在 Wondry 应用上或在你能获取播客的任何地方关注《莫比德》。你可以收听我们的播客《莫比德》。在 Wondry 应用上或在你能获取播客的任何地方关注《莫比德》。
You can listen to episodes early and ad free by joining Wondery Plus and the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过加入 Wondry Plus、Wondry 应用或苹果播客，你可以提前收听无广告的节目。这个单集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。